avec vous cette rencontre de la revue le
grand continent au Sénat
et d'inaugurer ainsi une série de temps
de dialogue et d'échanges autour d'un
jeu qui bien que varié auront un pivot
quel géographie des puissances dans un
monde en mutation
quelle place et quel projection pour
l'Union européenne et la France au-delà
de leur frontière vers les vastes
horizons du grand large et du grand
continent
ces enjeux
sont complexes à décrypter
il me semble indispensable de prendre le
temps de la réflexion et une certaine
distance
de s'offrir en quelque sorte le luxe de
la lenteur pour réinterroger revisiter
parfois les certitudes les idées reçues
les convictions
cela est d'ailleurs fidèle à l'un des
sites distinctifs du Sénat se tenir un
peu pas toujours
mais un peu à l'égard des pulsions du
moment
ou des modes et décider avec les seuls
boussoles de la sagesse et de la raison
je cite souvent la fontaine
du lièvre et de la tortue de la femme
symbole de sérénité et de sagesse qui va
sont en train de sénateur on sait que
c'est elle qui arrive à la première tout
en portant la maison
je tiens à saluer le travail remarquable
accompli par la commission des affaires
étrangères
de la défense et les forces armées sur
la direction de son président Christian
Cambon mais aussi le travail de notre
commission des affaires européennes et
de son président Jean-François Rapin
ces deux commissions sont au centre d'un
maillage dense de diplomates de
responsables politiques de décider en
économiques de représentants aussi du
monde académique qui éclaire leur
réflexion et guide l'élaboration d'avis
et de rapport dont la qualité je dois le
dire reconnu
je souhaite que nous puissions prolonger
les travaux de ces deux commissions du
Sénat
à travers la revue le grand continent
qui accueille les signatures les plus
prestigieuses venu des horizons les plus
variées en matière de politique
étrangère et de géopolitique nous semble
que l'occasion nous est donnée de
multiplier les passerelles avec le monde
académique et universitaire de permettre
à vous mes chers collègues sénateurs
quel que soit les commissions ou les
délégations dans lesquelles vous siiez
oui à vous tous d'échanger avec les
meilleures spécialistes de ces questions
complexes
ce que nous entreprenons et le contraire
en fait de formule à l'emporte-pièce ou
d'analyse toute faite qui triomphe par
ailleurs c'est peut-être quelque part
entre guillemets la fierté du Sénat à
l'heure où l'invective fait trop souvent
office de débat et prend en otage les
changes d'arguments
mesdames et messieurs dans la seconde
lettre de la crise de l'esprit
aux sortir de la Première Guerre
mondiale Paul Valéry poser les questions
qui ne cessent de hanter l'Europe depuis
plus d'un siècle et je cite Paul Valéry
l'Europe va-t-elle garder sa prééminence
dans tous les genres
interrogation
l'Europe deviendra-t-elle ce qu'elle est
en réalité c'est à dire un petit cap du
continent asiatique point
d'interrogation et je cite toujours
Valérie ou bien l'Europe restera-t-elle
ce qu'elle paraît troisième
interrogation
en convoquant les outils de la
géopolitique traditionnelle ancrée dans
l'histoire et la géographie mais aussi
les notions plus novatrices de
capitalisme politique ou de géo économie
vous allez à votre tour examiner ces
questions et tenter d'y apporter des
réponses
car l'Europe comme la France depuis plus
d'un siècle n'a cessé de se réinventer
de rechercher des alliances de nouer des
partenariats de reconstruire un modèle
de puissance abîmé dans deux guerres
mondiales
pour mieux s'affirmer dans un monde
qu'elle s'est mouvant
mais l'Europe et la France hésite aussi
ils hésitent aussi sur leur héritage sur
leurs actions passées sur ce qu'elles
sont
fondamentalement elles hésitent sur la
place et le rôle de l'État entre
libéralisme économique exercices de la
souveraineté au niveau national ou
fédéral construction balbutiante et
quand même tardive d'une autonomie
stratégique encore trop lacunaire
alors l'Europe n'est-elle plus que
l'ombre d'elle-même interrogation
l'Europe est-elle condamnée à se
conformer à sa réalité géographique qui
serait celle d'être un petit cap pour
reprendre les mots de Paul Valéry
un petit cap du grand continent
asiatique ou l'une des côtes du Grand
Large transatlantique interrogation que
je pose
l'Europe la France sont-elles condamnées
au paraître d'un lustre révolu voilà me
semble-t-il les questions
l'issue les mutations en cours n'est pas
écrite mais ces mutations sont aussi
fondamentales de celles qui vire au
XVIème siècle le monde méditerranéen
abandonné sa suprématie au profit du
monde transatlantique
dans cette équation les États européens
s'il perdaient leur position centrale
continuait à l'heure de figurer parmi
les partenaires essentiels
aujourd'hui le risque et qu'il ne soit
plus que l'extrémité la périphérie
d'entités géopolitique qui leur sont
étrangères concurrentes voire hostile
d'autant que la dorsale le rasiatique
c'est ensemble allant de l'Europe
occidentale à la Chine que chacun
ou en tous les cas d'aucun caressaient
comme une réponse continentale à la
polarisation Chine États-Unis les cyan
l'Union européenne en manque d'oxygène
oui d'autant que cette dorsale semblait
avoir fait naufrage avec l'agression de
l'Ukraine par la Russie
et que la stratégie ado pacifique de
l'Union européenne d'ailleurs à
l'initiative de la France
n'a pas atteint la masse critique encore
nécessaire et les pros dispersés pour
constituer à ce stade un contrepoids
dans les tensions entre la Chine et les
États-Unis
mesdames et messieurs je reprendrai une
expression chère un tout nouvel
académicien qui a écrit essentiellement
dans la langue espagnole Maria
vargaslausard
ces réflexions luminaires c'est au feu
crépitant des idées de vos idées un
formulant aveux pour l'Union européenne
et pour la France que les rencontres du
grand large et sevenus des profondeurs
du grand continent se rencontrent
et trouve en quelque sorte une forme de
neutralisation en un point d'équilibre
qui serait l'Europe je nous souhaite
d'excellents travaux à partager ce soir
merci et bienvenue au Sénat
[Applaudissements]
c'est le Président chers collègues
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
madame et Messieurs les directeurs
mesdames et messieurs et chers amis
permettez-moi tout d'abord de vous
remercier d'avoir bien voulu associer la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées du Sénat à
ce dialogue à cette soirée de de
réflexion réflexion géopolitique
géostratégique et géo économie tout à la
fois nous croyons en effet je salue mes
collègues nombreux qui ont souhaité se
joindre à cette soirée
nous pensons en effet nous les
parlementaires que nous avons aussi un
rôle à jouer dans la réflexion et dans
l'analyse de ces recompositions
géopolitiques qui fragilisent les
Mondiaux
hérités de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
sur le sujet qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
la rivalité entre les États-Unis et la
Chine je rappelle que la Commission a
adopté pas moins de trois rapports
récents le dernier sur la nécessaire
adaptation de la stratégie française
dans l'Indopacifique adaptation aux
réalités géostratégiques actuelles
la France en effet se veut puissance
d'équilibre ou puissance stabilisatrice
ce fait nous avons toujours recherché le
dialogue avec chaque pays y compris et
surtout dans les situations de tension
géostratégique où les situations de
conflits se positionnement est du reste
parfois mal compris de la part des
interlocuteurs de la France au point de
devenir parfois même contre-productif
pour nos intérêts est-il en adéquation
avec notre poids réel et surtout et
surtout sommes-nous prêts à consacrer
les moyens nécessaires à de si grandes
ambitions
notre époque se caractérise par la
bipolarisation la bimondialisation sur
structurée autour de groupes de pays
rivaux menés par les États-Unis d'un
côté et la Chine de l'autre
l'affrontement des États-Unis et de la
Chine a longtemps paru peu vraisemblable
et même un peu théorique certes certains
chercheurs se sont inquiétés de ce que
l'on appelle communément le piège de
tussidite c'est-à-dire le caractère
probable d'une guerre entre la puissance
dominante du moment avec sa rivale
ascendante qui aspire à dominer la phase
suivante mais en l'espèce l’imbrication
économique des États-Unis et de la Chine
le risque démographique auquel se
heurtait la Chine avec un vieillissement
trop précoce de sa main d'oeuvre
phénomène qui semble se confirmer
l'endettement record des États-Unis dont
une partie essentielle de la dette était
détenue par la Chine tous ces facteurs
multiples nous laissaient penser que la
concurrence serait sans violence sans
confrontation voire n'aurait pas lieu du
tout
aujourd'hui force est de constater que
cette vision était particulièrement
optimiste pas plus que les dividendes de
la paix n'ont duré cet espoir d'une
pacification durable du monde par la
mondialisation et le commerce n'a pas
résisté au retour des politiques de
puissance des états
l'agression russe en Ukraine débutait il
y a un an quasiment jour pour jour
constitue très vraisemblablement une
rupture dans l'histoire de l'Union
européenne et une rupture dans
l'histoire de l'équilibre mondiale
l'affrontement direct violent meurtrier
et redevenu possible la confrontation
armée gagne en crédibilité beaucoup
d'analystes ont estimé que l'Ukraine
était un laboratoire dont la Chine
pourrait tirer des leçons pour s'occuper
de Taïwan
dans le même temps la péninsule coréenne
semble pouvoir basculer à tout moment
dans une escalade remédiable comme en
témoigne les ressentir de missiles de la
Corée militaire sa parade militaire
gigantesque du 8 février dernier
l'affirmation de ses ambitions dans le
domaine de la défense de manière
économique et même civilisationnel de
son dirigeant
tout à côté la découverte d'un important
gisement de lithium dans le cachemire
pourrait aussi aiguiser les appétits
dans cette région alors que les heures
meurtriers à la frontière entre la Chine
et l'Inde n'ont pas totalement cessé
depuis leur reprise en 2020
le rapprochement entre l'Iran et la
Chine qui viennent se caractériser par
la visite officielle ces jours derniers
du président iranien à Pékin s'appuie
sur un accord de coopération stratégique
et commercial à 25 ans
dernière étape de cette montée en
tension le survol de l'Amérique du Nord
par des ballons chinois soupçonnés
d'espionnage
à la date du 12 février 4 ballons avait
déjà été abattu du sol à partir du sol
américain dans le ciel de l'Alaska et
au-dessus du Canada les autorités
chinoises ont répliqué que des ballons
américains ont survolé leur territoire à
plus de 10 reprises sans autorisation en
l'espace d'un an ces incidents qui
peuvent paraître mineurs ont et auront
vraisemblablement des conséquences
concrètes déjà avec le report de la
visite en Chine du secrétaire d'État
américain ainsi les tensions
s'exaspèrent et s'exerbe pardon les
risques de confrontation se multiplient
et rien n'empêche que les divers
scénarios des crises soi-même cumulatif
je tiens d'ailleurs je tiens d'abord à
souligner que la majorité des pays n'ont
pas condamné ou ont condamné sans
prononcer de sanctions l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie la Chine pour sa
part a indiqué comprendre je cite les
préoccupations raisonnables de la Russie
en matière de sécurité
la porte des États-Unis dans le soutien
de l'Ukraine et massif et essentiel
est-ce que l'apport européen aurait pu
suffire on peut vraisemblablement en
douter et pourtant la politique
américaine a effectué son pivot
asiatique asiatique le soutien américain
l'Ukraine ne remet pas en cause ce pivot
le dernier rapport de notre commission
sur l'Indo Pacifique propose des cartes
très intéressantes et très éclairantes
je vous y renvoie elles illustrent
combien le basculement du monde autour
de la rivalité États-Unis Chine place
l'Europe et singulièrement la France en
périphérie du monde c'est bien une
révolution copernicienne que nous sommes
donc invités à faire alors essayez un
peu notre sujet ce soir quelle place
reste-t-il pour les ambitions françaises
et européennes
l'Ukraine a été l'occasion d'un réveil
géopolitique des Européens
coordonnées entre les différents États
membres de l'Union la rapidité des états
me pour négocier puis pour mettre en
œuvre 9 vagues de sanction d'une ampleur
inédite contre l'économie russe ont
apporté un démenti éloquent à l'idée
selon laquelle l'Europe serait condamnée
sur la scène internationale à la
paralysie ou même à la division tout
comme l'activation inédite et rapide de
la facilité européenne pour la paix
mais nous ne pourrons être à la hauteur
des nouveaux enjeux géostratégiques qu'à
trois conditions cumulatives à notre
sens
en tout premier nous devons être capable
de définir dans le reste des
spécificités de chacun une culture
stratégique commune à l'échelle de
l'Union une volonté d'agir ensemble sur
la scène internationale pour défendre
nos intérêts communs
en second point nous devons nous donner
les moyens de cette ambition pour être
crédible et donc nous doter à la fois
des financements nécessaires mais aussi
d'un outil industriel solide et
indépendant singulièrement dans le
domaine de la défense
enfin nous devons adapter nos stratégies
françaises et européennes à la volonté
hégémonique de la Chine qui l'a affirmé
lors du 20e congrès du Parti communiste
chinois partenaire et compétiteur
commercial incontournables la Chine
s'affirme ainsi comme un rival
systémique de plus en plus offensif
devons-nous pour autant négliger de
défendre nos propres intérêts face à
notre grand allié américain dans ce
domaine nous pensons que la France doit
défendre une politique forte et réaliste
l'Union européenne est un des blocs
économiques les plus performants cela
doit nous permettre de définir notre
propre cette stratégie guidé d'abord et
avant tout par les intérêts européens il
en va de notre propre sécurité
avant de laisser la parole à Gilles
graissani directeur de la revue le grand
continent et Matteo Malik rédacteur en
chef je voudrais à nouveau me réjouir au
nom de notre commission de ce moment
d'échange au Sénat car du débat et de la
confrontation des analyses née la
lucidité dont nous avons tous
collectivement besoin dans ces temps
troublés je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président du Sénat monsieur
le président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs Mesdames et Messieurs les
Ambassadeurs mesdames et messieurs et
surtout
j'aime insister sur ce site chers
lecteur merci pour votre présence nous
sommes vraiment très heureux que cette
première édition des Rencontres du grand
continent au Sénat soit d'or et des gens
un succès d'affluence et dans la lignée
de ce qui vient d'être dit par le
président du Sénat et par le président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées que
nous remercions encore une fois pour
leur soutien à leur accueil l'exercice
que nous inauguons aujourd'hui nous
paraît la fois
utile et original
utile d'abord parce que il nous permet
de structurer un débat public informé
ouvert d'un autre époque de
transformation profonde parce qu'il est
au coeur de l'appréhension du temps long
et qu'il à l'écoute de tendances de fond
le Sénat est un partenaire auquel le
grand continent notre revue est
particulièrement fier de sa société
cette année dans le cas d'un cycle qui
commence aujourd'hui
ce cycle est aussi original car ce
dialogue est nécessaire entre le savoir
et la décision et ce dialogue est au
cœur de notre démarche ainsi que de
celle du groupe des touches de
politiques notre éditeur qui est
identifier des lieux des occasions pour
qu'ils puissent se déployer d'une façon
convelable et nouvelle à cet égard c'est
un compte ce sont donc une occasion
privilégiée de faire dialoguer des
signatures de la revue avec des
sénateurs des commissions concernées
pour apporter un éclairage nouveau libre
et ouvert bénéficiant du regard croisé
entre par la Nanterre et expert
un petit mot sur la sur la revue donc
nous existons depuis 2019 c'est peu par
rapport à l'histoire du Sénat mais voilà
c'est important pour nous et nous sommes
donnés d'emblée l'ambition d'être la
revue ou une des revues de référence du
débat stratégique politique intellectuel
à l'échelle de l'Europe
aujourd'hui le grand routine est une
principale revue ce n'est pas la
première revue de l'espace francophone
par le nombre de signatures vous voyez
le calibre de nos signatures une
sélection de nos signatures à ma droite
et évidemment aussi par le nombre de
lecteurs nos articles sont désormais
discutés et commentés par toi en Europe
grâce à une stratégie éditoriale qui est
très importante parce que elle est
fondée sur le plurilinguisme le publiant
un français un espagnol en italien un
allemand et en polonais pour essayer de
faire vivre le débat à l'échelle du
continent vous trouverez nos
publications à LIBRAIRIE avec le premier
volume qui est paru chez Gallimard
politique de l'intérêt que je vous
montre et sur le site web le grand
continent un point a eu
et encore une fois nous sommes vraiment
absolument ravis d'organiser au milieu
des événements que nous porte de
Varsovie assez vie et de Paris jusqu'à
Naples en passant par Berlin et Vienne
et bien à partir d'aujourd'hui nous
sommes ravis d'être au Palais du
Luxembourg donc d'accord merci pour
votre école
merci beaucoup agile pour ces mots et
merci encore une fois à vous
l'époque que nous traversons et
bouleversée elle est heurté de crise
après la pandémie et depuis l'invasion
de l'Ukraine nous assistons à des
recompositions géopolitiques à l'échelle
mondiale sur lesquelles je ne reviendrai
pas parce que les enjeux en ont été
parfaitement exposés par les présidents
Larcher et quand bon
qui finalement ont posé la question
selon nous dans les bons termes c'est à
dire comment la France et l'Europe se
situent-elles aujourd'hui dans ce grand
contexte c'est une question évidemment
très complexe et pour cette première
séance de ce cycle que nous sommes
encore une fois très fiers de débuter
aujourd'hui nous avons choisi au Sénat
de prendre de la hauteur
pour étudier des problèmes aussi
concrets
et aussi finalement
urgent que par exemple la disruption du
commerce international les problèmes
aussi précis et aussi complexes et
techniques que celui des
semi-conducteurs ou des chaînes
d'approvisionnement nous partirons du
capitalisme politique pression que
président Larcher a mentionné tout à
l'heure et qui nous permet finalement
d'être un point d'entrée pour articuler
l'échelle de la rivalité globale Chine
États-Unis qui nous occupent aujourd'hui
avec celle des nanotechnologies cette
expression est de Max Weber elle a été
étudiée plus en détail dans un texte
auquel je vous renvoie ce premier volume
papier du grand continent par Alessandro
Azu dans politique de l'intérêt pour
désigner finalement l’imbrication
instrumentale et réelle des objectifs
économiques et des exigences de sécurité
nationale
en Chine aux États-Unis mais aussi en
Europe et en France les forces de
l'économie sont de plus en plus mises au
service de la sécurité dans cette
composition globale que nous évoquons
et c'est donc de notre situation dans
cette dans ce contexte que nous allons
essayer de questionner avec vous et
grâce aux éclairages de nos quatre
invités de nos quatre intervenants que
nous remercions encore une fois
gillespel titulaire de la chaire
Méditerranée Moyen-Orient à l'École
normale supérieure PSL qui commencera
par présenter les grandes lignes de
fractures géopolitiques après l'invasion
de l'Ukraine au Moyen-Orient et en
méditer et en Méditerranée en
particulier entre non alignements et
nouveaux partenariat dans un paysage
d'alliance bouleversé Louis de cateux
quant à lui qui codirige avec Alessandro
a raison que j'évoquais à l'instant la
série capitalisme politique en guerre
publiée dans les colonnes du grand
continent avec un article Paressant
chaque mercredi sur notre site Web et
qui nous parlera dans son intervention
qui cherchera dans son intervention plus
précisément à étudier le point nodal de
cette géopolitique contemporaine donc la
rivalité entre la Chine et les
États-Unis en fonction de la capacité
politique des deux systèmes à diriger
transformer
développer l'innovation l'industrie et
les technologies numériques et les
sciences
Alice panier vous êtes responsable du
programme de géopolitique des
technologies à l'Institut français des
relations internationales vous avez
signé aujourd'hui même dans le grand
continent un article absolument
passionnant que je vous invite à lire
sur les technologies critiques les
technologies émergentes et leur rôle
géopolitique vous aborderez aujourd'hui
la place de l'Europe dans la rivalité
technologique entre la Chine et les
États-Unis enfin Sébastien Jean
professeur d'économie titulaire de la
chair d'Économie Industrielle
Jean-Baptiste Say au CNAM vous nous
parlerez du bouleversement de l'ordre
économique et commercialement
économie dans une nouvelle phase de la
mondialisation les interventions d'une
durée approximative de 10 minutes seront
suivies d'un échange avec la salle avant
les mots de conclusion par le président
du Sénat nous ne serons pas plus longs
je vous remercie encore une fois et je
l'honneur de céder la parole à Gilles
Kepel pour la première intervention
[Applaudissements]
ça commence mal pour la technologie bien
monsieur le Président du Sénat cher
Gérard Larcher monsieur le Président de
la Commission aux affaires étrangères de
la défense des forces armées chez
Christian Campbon Mesdames et Messieurs
les vices présidentes monsieur les
sénateurs chers collègues chers amis je
suis aussi ému je pense que les jeunes
gens qui dirigent le grand continent des
petits des années que nous sépare d'eux
de cette opportunité que nous avons de
rassembler ici la première chambre du
Parlement français avec des initiatives
intellectuelles les plus éclatantes et
les plus exigeantes qui se produisent
aujourd'hui au sein de notre université
et qui irrigue le monde à la fois de
l'édition et des médias c'est un moment
très important pour nous et je voudrais
le souligner et vous remercier monsieur
le Président d'avoir accepté
de mettre en oeuvre ce qui était d'abord
une idée folle et puis qui finalement se
retrouve une idée sage en ce qui me
concerne mon rôle est simplement
d'introduire le débat en présentant
quelques quelques exemples ou quelques
quelques
[Musique]
hypothèses paradigmatiques que mes
collègues qui sont beaucoup plus versées
dans la thématique de ce jour pourront
ensuite développer à leur crime alors
évidemment
à partir du moment où on parle de ligne
de faille et de nouvelles lignes de fin
et je ne peux pas ne pas me pencher sur
l'actualité et la métaphore terrible que
nous produisent réelles là les deux
tremblements de terre les deux séismes
qui viennent de se produire en Turquie
paradoxalement ou pas paradoxalement je
ne sais pas illustre assez bien ce
propos
comme vous le savez
ce sont tremblement de terre qui ont
l'air tout à fait stupéfiant mais qui
sont en réalité des constantes très
anciennes de l'histoire de la terre
puisque Antioche avait déjà tremblé à
l'époque où l'empereur Trajan était en
route vers pour la guerre contre les
partes l'Irak actuel ensuite Antioche
avait été détruite au sixième siècle
pour de bons la plus grande ville de
l'Empire byzantin suivi de pillage de
scènes d'insécurité terrible qui évoque
celle d'aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui
c'est deux failles la faille Est-Ouest
la faille Nord-Sud
Karaman malash les pissantes est situé
la triple jonction entre le plateau
anatolien le plâtre le monde arabique le
monde africain la faille de la Mer Morte
tout cela finalement
est une métaphore c'est une métonymie
assez frappante de ce phénomène où on a
le sentiment que
les alliances les ce qui pouvait mettre
ensemble le monde depuis
1945 et parti dans tous les sens et
ce phénomène de désaffiliation si l'on
peut dire que
qui se manifeste un peu partout et
au fond la rivalité entre la Chine et
les États-Unis qui est l'intitulé de ce
de ce colloque vient
se substituer
sans ce superposer à ce qui avait été
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale une
sorte de congélation du monde dans
l'opposition de la guerre froide
justement entre
l'URSS et des États-Unis entre le monde
soviétique ou socialiste et le monde
libre au capitaliste
et qui paradoxalement avait fait que les
Européens que nous sommes n'avaient pas
connu le conflit sur leur territoire
véritablement en tout cas avec il y
avait eu des conflits en yoslavie
notamment mais pas avec l'ampleur
extraordinaire avec le déclenchement
sismique si je puis
qui est celui de la guerre du crâne
présente sur notre sol donc là le mode
de régulation qui avait été déconstruit
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
n'existe plus et la mondialisation qui
voit la la concurrence
sino-américaine se déployait
se transformer et autres nous contraint
à penser à nouveau frais avec on
élaborant des concepts qui seront
développés par mes collègues dans un
instant là scène internationale sur
laquelle nous vivons une seule
internationale dont je voudrais
souligner les sénateurs ici présents
bien évidemment le savent qui se traduit
sur la scène nationale puisque on a plus
simplement des oppositions sur la scène
nationale entre ceux qui soutiennent
l'URSS et ceux qui soutiennent les
États-Unis comme au bon vieux temps mais
la projection dans un certain nombre de
nos territoires
de conflits opposant un certain nombre
de nos partenaires à l'international
voir regroupant diverses coalitions qui
n'ont plus rien à voir avec celle du
passé et j'ai eu l'honneur récemment de
faire une mission pour le président de
la République sur la relation entre un
certain nombre des forces qui s'exercent
dans divers départements français et les
pays dont sont ressortissants certains
des habitants de ces départements et on
voit bien que cette intrication n'est
pas seulement un enjeu géopolitique
c'est aussi un enjeu de politique
française et ça c'est quelque chose de
particulièrement important alors très
brièvement
qu'il me reste trois ou quatre minutes
ce que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec
ce que révèle le le double séisme turc
et syrien
va tout à fait dans le sens de ce qui a
été mentionné et de l'objet de nos de
nos travaux en effet
on voit que les alliances par exemple
qui avaient été construite par le
président
Erdogan avec les rebelles syriens puis
le
l'accueil des réfugiés le soutien aux
islamistes de tendances Frères musulmans
proches de la de la vision qui est celle
de du parti de Monsieur
Erdogan la capé par exemple sont
aujourd'hui en train d'être complètement
remises en cause puisque les Russes qui
exercent leur ascendant sur la Syrie et
le président Hassad n'a pu se rendre à
Alep que parce que les Russes sont
autorisés à le faire l'autre jour les
Russes ont poussé énormément les Turcs à
se réconcilier avec le président Hassan
donc on a là une ligne de faille très
bizarre très concret qui se perturbe
Est-Ouest Sud Nord qui se mélangent les
rebelles syriens qui étaient soutenus
par la Turquie ne savent plus si j'ose
dire à quel saint se vouer et
cette situation
contribue à un effet de catastrophe dans
la région
par exemple dans la région rebelle
soutenu par les Turcs aucune aide n'est
arrivée donc la situation est absolument
catastrophique vous avez évoqué sur le
président tout à l'heure la visite que
le Président de la République islamique
monsieur raïti est fait vient
d'effectueux effectuer encore toujours
en Chine ou le donc reçu par le
président chinois
celui-ci a
réaffirmé ces liens avec avec la
République populaire de Chine et ce qui
avait même été du reste très critiqué
sous le le président le Presson
prédécesseur puisque un certain nombre
de parlementaires on pense toujours que
le Parlement iranien est aux ordres
iranien avait critiqué
l'assujettissement de l'Iran à la Chine
qui leur semblait pire c'était
ahmadinedja qui avait expliqué ça que
l'ancienne impérialisme américain donc
on a si vous voulez des choses qui sont
tout à fait stupéfiantes ce qui m'a
aussi beaucoup frappé dans la mission
que j'ai fait récemment c'est qu'un
certain nombre de nos partenaires disons
historiques ou traditionnels dans les
pays du Maghreb aujourd'hui et maintenu
les ministres ont tenu les propos
m'expliquant que le Maghreb de
grand-papa ou de papa ont été terminé
que il n'était pas question de donner
par un temps mouvement naturel ou un
penchant naturel là la préférence a des
alliances avec l'Europe ou avec la
France les votes à l'occasion de la
guerre en Ukraine l'ont dur amplement
démontrée et que si tel ou tel pays du
Maghreb où l'on pensait être en
[Musique]
cousinage en très grande proximité en
tout cas
estimait que les accords d'Abraham lui
permettait d'avoir un meilleur une
opportunité avec Israël ou avec la Chine
ou avec la Russie et bien c'est sur la
base une contractualisation libre qu'il
allait choisir c'est sa tactique ou ses
stratégies alors tout ça bien sûr créer
une complexité
dans le décryptage la lecture des
relations internationales dont je vous
réitère aussi qu'elles ont des
incidences sur la scène sur les scènes
nationales
particulièrement difficile à penser
puisque le tout l'appareil conceptuel
qui a été construit pour penser des
relations internationales depuis la fin
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale et jusqu'à
au moment où la chute du mur de Berlin
avait opposé d'un côté le clash des
civilisations à la fin de l'histoire
tout pas aujourd'hui semble très en deçà
pour nous permettre de penser les
conflits auxquels nous sommes confrontés
donc après avoir dit ces quelques mots
limitait liminaires pardon pour
introduire la plus grande confusion
maintenant je vous laisse le travail de
remettre tout ça en forme et comme le
disait les chevalesa il est beaucoup
plus difficile de refaire un boeuf à
partir du board que un board à partir du
boeuf donc moi j'ai fait le bord c'est
maintenant je vous laisse refaire le
bœuf merci beaucoup et
toutes mes j'attends avec impatience
voir comment vous allez vous tirer de ce
défi merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
donc effectivement lui dirige auprès du
grand continent la série capitalisme
politique en guerre et qui a après ce
portrait très très brillant et très
synthétique des nouvelles recomposition
géopolitiques la charge d'essayer de
nous introduire à cette notion qui est
celle du capitalisme politique montrer
en quoi il est parti en pertinent
aujourd'hui pour rentrer au cœur de la
rivalité
merci pour le Défi monsieur Kepel
donc monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président a commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et les forces
armées messieurs et mesdames les
sénateurs messieurs les membres du corps
diplomatique et Cher publique j'ai envie
de vous parler de ce qui me semble être
deux dynamiques clés dans la
géopolitique mondiale aujourd'hui
c'est à dire la sécurité
de l'économie persécute par sécurité ce
que j'entends c'est le fait que les
activités économiques notamment les
échanges et les investissements ne sont
plus envisagés uniquement sous l'angle
économique mais sous celui de l'an de la
sécurité nationale ce sont devenus des
vrais problèmes pour les administrations
en charge de la sécurité la recherche
d'efficacité doit parfois laisser place
aux objectifs de résilience ou de
maîtrise
et on voit ça par exemple dans les plans
qui visent à développer l'industrie des
semi-conducteurs pour des questions de
sécurité
en rompant avec la logique des chaînes
de valeur mondiales
le deuxième point c'est l'arsenalisation
ça c'est le fait d'utiliser les
interdépendance économiques et leur
nature asymétrique pour imposer ses vues
et avancer ses propres intérêts les
sanctions financières américaines par
exemple comme l'expliquait très bien
dans un des articles de notre série
Agathe de marais repose sur sur pardon
le caractère central du dollar dans le
système économique mondial le fait que
les banques ont besoin d'accéder au
dollar et qu'à partir du moment où les
États-Unis menacent de les couper du
dollar on a
une acceptation et même souvent de la
surconformité aux sanctions
c'est ces deux évolutions qui ont amené
à les endroits à résoudre cet article
pour le grand pour politique de
l'intérêt à parler de
capitalisme politique en guerre c'est
intéressant parce que le terme avait été
utilisé par Bronco Milanovic mais pour
lui il y avait un capitalisme politique
chinois autoritaire en lutte face à un
capitaliste libéral démocratique et
je vais suivre Alessandro en ça
il met le point sur la forte relation
inter-relation entre l'économique et le
militaire aux États-Unis il y a une
vraie tradition là dessus
il y a à la fois le poids de la défense
dans l'économie politique américaine le
diody c'est le principal
budget du gouvernement fédéral américain
c'est 800 milliards de dollars 4% du PIB
c'est aussi quelque chose c'est aussi
par sa voix que il a eu un rôle
instrumental dans la naissance de
nombreuses technologies on connaît tous
l'exemple d'ARPANET et l'Internet mais
plus largement de la Silicon Valley
et le deuxième point c'est la tradition
d'économique step craft qui est un terme
qui est difficilement traduisible
américaine et ce qui veut dire le fait
d'utiliser des outils économiques pour
poursuivre des objectifs de politique
étrangère du plan d'eau au plan Marshall
de la création du comcom c'est à dire de
des contrôles export de tous les alliés
d'Anto pendant la guerre froide à aux
lois elsburton dans les années 90 qui
renforçait les sections contre les
sanctions pardon contre Cuba les
États-Unis ont toujours su utiliser leur
poids économique pour aider quand ils en
avaient envie ou bloqué quand ils en
avaient besoin
et je pense que en suivant là encore
Alessandro on peut parler aujourd'hui de
capitalisme politique américain
ce capitalisme politique américain on en
a le programme c'est un discours de Jake
Sullivan prononcé le 16 septembre à la
remise du rapport du
Project et ce programme il a quatre axes
le premier c'est investir dans
l'écosystème scientifique et
technologique le deuxième c'est faire
émerger des talents le troisième c'est
protéger l'avantage technologique des
États-Unis et le quatrième c'est
approfondir les alliances et
partenariats investir dans l'écosystème
scientifique et technologique sur la
recherche c'est et Alice vous en parlera
mieux c'est
identifier définir des technologies
critiques et mettre en place des
soutiens par exemple il y a eu sous la
présidence Trump la National quantum
initiative pour faire le lien aussi avec
la sécurité il y a tout ce qui a découlé
de la National Security commission aïe
sur l'intelligence artificielle
c'est la recherche mais c'est aussi le
déploiement ça c'est les grands plans
politique industriels de
l'administration Biden le chipsa Act
pour les semi-conducteurs et je crois
que c'est monsieur le Président du Sénat
qui en parlait l'infection réduction Act
sur les technologies vertes
faire émerger les talents c'est aussi
des subventions des programmes qui sont
prévus dans le chips and science
protéger l'avantage technologies des
États-Unis c'est la sécurité économique
par exemple le fait que le FBI regarde
de plus en plus près les coopérations
entre les universités chinoises et les
centres de recherche américain ce qu'ils
ont appelé la China initiative c'est les
contrôles exports on a beaucoup parlé en
octobre avec des premiers contrôles qui
avaient été mis en place ou
l'administration Trump et qui ont été
renforcés pour empêcher l'exportation de
tout ce qui sert à faire des des puces
de dernière technologie notamment celles
qui sont utilisées pour faire tourner
des modèles d'intelligence artificielle
et dernière idée en date quelque chose
qui est en discussion et beaucoup de
discussions Washington autour d'un futur
exetive order sur un contrôle les
investissements quelque chose qu'on fait
en France et qu'on a fait en Europe mais
pas un contrôle des investissements
entrants il existe déjà c'est le comité
US ce qui va le faire c'est un contrôle
des investissements sortants pour éviter
des transferts de technologie
approfondir les alliances et
partenariats c'est introduire une
dimension technologique et sur les
chaînes d'approvisionnement dans toutes
les grandes alliances le titre ici avec
l'Europe le trident technology
des questions technologiques très
traitées au sein du quad l'alliance avec
l'Australie le Japon l'Inde et bien sûr
les États-Unis et l'internalisation des
contrôles export qu'on a vu avec un
accord avec le Japon les Pays-Bas et la
Corée du Sud
et face à ces États-Unis on a bien sûr
le capitalisme politique chinois il y a
une vraie volonté chez dicksimping de
faire de la Chine une grande puissance
scientifique et technologique en
mobilisant tous les moyens de l'État
central mais aussi des gouvernements
opérations des entreprises
d'État et aussi du secteur privé je
pense qu'un cas d'étude très intéressant
et
encore une fois
il faut lire notre série avec un article
très intéressant de Chris Miller
là-dessus c'est le cas de
semi-conducteurs
aujourd'hui
la Chine et l'atelier du monde et
consomme énormément de semi-conducteurs
pour produire de l'électronique mais les
semis conducteurs ne sont pas produits
en Chine en 2015 quand il lance China le
programme China 2025 15% uniquement des
besoins chinois son produit sur le
territoire ces 250 milliards
d'importations c'est plus que de le
pétrole
après un certain nombre de programmes
notamment le chipsfund qui était
assez marrant Chris Miller explique
qu'il y a de l'argent de tout même du
monopole d'états pour financer le
développement de l'industrie des
semi-conducteurs
ils sont toujours qu'à 20% ils avaient
prévu de faire 70 % en 2025 ils sont à
20% aujourd'hui c'est un secteur
compliqué les contrôles des exportations
Américains ne vont pas les aider à
atteindre leurs objectifs
mais le capitalisme politique chinois a
des tours dans son sac il y a très
récemment
130 milliards de dollars qui ont été
annoncés en soutien au secteur des semis
conducteurs et des discussions pour eux
aussi utiliser les interdépendances
appuyer là où ça fait mal il y a des
très récemment le ministère chinois des
technologies a lancé des consultations
pour la mise en place de licences
d'exportation pour non pas les panneaux
photovoltaïques mais pour les
technologies nécessaires à la production
de panneaux voltaïques soit une première
étape à la mise en place de contrôle
export et quand on voit les besoins
notamment avec le plan européen de
de soutien aux industries vertes bien
sûr à ce que font les Etats-Unis là
aussi on est dans une vraie logique
d'arsenalization et de réponse à la
politique américaine
donc aujourd'hui dans ce monde post
guerre froide
le paon le monde post-guerre froide
était marqué par une plus grande
intégration économique régulée par des
règles dont le principal symbole c'est
sans doute la création de l'OMC et
l'entrée ensuite de la Chine et de la
Russie au sein de ceci et en train de
prendre fin il y a une analyse très
intéressante du FMI là dessus sur la la
fragmentation géoconomique est-ce que ça
veut dire pour le multilatéralisme il y
aura une interview bientôt dans le grand
continent pour pour exploiter le mieux
comprendre leurs arguments et comprendre
les dynamiques en cours ça nécessite la
fin de ce monde parksg guerre froide de
repenser notre insertion dans la
mondialisation c'est à dire à la fois de
créer les outils pour assurer notre
sécurité et développer notre industrie
mais aussi peut-être quelque chose dont
on a moins l'habitude par rapport aux
États-Unis
de développer une capacité d'économic
statecraft ce qui était de dire être
capable de limiter par des comme ils
font peut-être par des contrôles export
mais aussi d'utiliser le poids
économique pour
influencer restructurer les relations
internationales c'est ce qu'on a été
capable de faire avec l'Europe de l'Est
en intégrant dans l'Union européenne
c'est peut-être ce qu'on peut faire avec
la rive-sud de la Méditerranée pour
développer les industries vertes en
profitant du fait que il y a il y a de
l'espace et du soleil et des
collaborations à penser il y a un très
bon policy Pepper du gèle sur ce sujet
merci à tous
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup Louis
d'avoir
plus que survolé être entré dans le
détail de capitalisme politique chinois
et américain je laisse donc Alice panier
évoqué le cas de l'Europe à travers
peut-être l'exemple des technologies
émergentes
merci beaucoup
au Sénat et au grand continent pour pour
l'invitation merci aussi à Louis d'avoir
tout à fait bien introduit finalement
mon propos en présentant le contexte
international et les enjeux qui se
soulèvent qui se contexte soulève pour
l'Europe
les capacités d'investissement et
l'innovation de la Chine et des
États-Unis font que c'est deux
puissances sont à la pointe dans nombre
de domaines on connaît le problème de
des retards européens dans de nombreuses
technologies numériques notamment
on voit aussi que c'est puissances
technologiques s'accompagnent de
pratique politique au diplomatiques qui
placent l'Europe mais aussi le reste du
monde dans une situation assez
incortable d'une part la volonté
américaine de découplage et ses
pressions diplomatiques
y compris sur par exemple les Pays-Bas
et le Japon qui ont entraîné des choix
en matière de nouveaux contrôles
d'exportation et semi-conducteurs et
d'autre part évidemment la coercition
économique et les pratiques déloyales
menées par la Chine pour l'acquisition
et peut-être l'export de technologie
donc l'enjeu pour l'Europe c'est à la
fois d'accéder aux technologies malgré
ou en évitant les contrôles et les
restrictions qui peuvent s'imposer aussi
à l'Europe et mais peut-être plutôt de
maîtriser les technologies c'est à dire
d'être capable de répondre aux besoins
de l'État et des sociétés dans un nombre
de domaines je pense à l'état parce que
même au sein de l'État même au cœur de
l'État même au sein du ministère des
armées on utilise des logiciels
Microsoft
ce qui pose parfois des difficultés
je vais pas m'étendre sur le sujet mais
ce qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que
cette technologie sur lesquelles
reposent aussi l'activité de l'État et
compris dans les domaines les plus
sensibles
reposent également sur des standards
technologiques des standards de
cybersécurité et la nécessité de la
maîtrise des technologies c'est aussi la
maîtrise de ces standards et de du degré
de cybersécurité de protection des
données qui soient conformes à nos
besoins et à nos valeurs mais au-delà de
ça c'est bien plus large ces enjeux
c'est évidemment un des enjeux de
compétitivité sur le long terme pour les
technologies numériques et plus
largement les technologies critiques
c'est pourquoi elles sont au cœur
aujourd'hui des ambitions de
souveraineté technologiques européennes
dont on parle depuis principalement
depuis 2019 et plus encore depuis le
covid
une petite perspective historique nous
permet de revenir sur cette ambition de
souveraineté technologique et nous
rendre compte que c'est pas uniquement
dans le cas américain qu'on a eu un lien
fort entre l'État et la production de
technologie
initialement à des fins militaires mais
avec des portées bien plus larges et des
implications y compris sur la conquête
de marché ensuite dans le domaine civil
ou commercial comme on dit en France
évidemment la volonté d'autonomie
stratégique notamment dans le cadre de
du développement d'une dissuasion
nucléaire indépendante et aussi cette
volonté d'indépendance de la politique
étrangère c'est à dire garder des marges
de manœuvre en politique étrangère donc
ces ambitions militaires et stratégiques
de la France l'ont amené ont amené
l'État français à mieux des
développements dans les technologies y
compris de nature dual
télécommunications spatiales
informatiques technologiques et
aujourd'hui font encore la force de la
France et de l'Europe dans certains
domaines
donc ça a reposer sur une implication
forte de l'État dans le pilotage du
développement de ces technologies y
compris à l'étape de la recherche donc
on peut faire un parallèle entre cette
ambition historique et les technologies
émergentes aujourd'hui dans la mesure où
la recherche et la science plus
généralement sont au cœur et notamment
la recherche publique sont au cœur du
développement des technologies dites
émergentes ces technologies émergentes
sont celles qui notamment parmi les
technologies qu'on va dire critiques
cybersécurité spatiale intelligence
artificielle
matériaux robotique etc sont celles qui
ne sont pas encore matures qui sont
encore au stade de la recherche et
expérimentation et qui pour beaucoup ont
un fort potentiel de rupture qu'on pense
à dans l'intelligence artificielle
l'apprentissage profond les technologies
quantiques dans toute leur division les
nanomatériaux etc
en ce qu'elle proviennent de la
recherche
y compris de la recherche publique et de
ce qu'elles ont ce fort potentiel de
rupture c'est c'est technologies
émergentes sont un levier pour une
souveraineté technologique française
européenne sur le long terme
et d'ailleurs on a des signes
encourageants de la place de l'Europe
dans ces technologies émergentes y
compris dans le cantique ou selon une
récente étude l'écosystème européen et
dans bien des domaines le plus avancé au
niveau mondial notamment dans les
les ordinateurs quantiques
alors puisque cette technologie
émergente et critique sont six
stratégies qu'elles sont effectivement
en phase d'être sécurisées de devenir
des enjeux de sécurité nationale et
d'être pris en compte comme tel ce qui
pose un ensemble de domaines un ensemble
de dilemmes pardon alors la sécurité des
technologies se trouvent à différents
niveaux la sécurisation des sécurités
sécurisations des chaînes de valeur on
en a parlé beaucoup au moment du covid
la sécurisation des industries notamment
face aux investissements étrangers
qui ne seraient pas souhaitable ou des
rachats par des par des pays étrangers
de pépites ou d'entreprises très
stratégiques mais aussi une sécurité de
la recherche elle-même ce qui pose un
ensemble de dilemmes notamment la
question de la souveraineté ou de la
fermeture par rapport à l'ouverture dans
la mesure où la recherche scientifique
en autarcie est impossible
évidemment pour mener une recherche de
qualité
il faut pour sa publier dans des revues
à comité de lecture qui sont disponibles
par des abonnements mais qui sont
accessibles à tous et aussi par la
reproduction d'expérience et
d'expérimentation pour valider des
concepts qui ensuite vont mener des
technologies de rupture
par ailleurs la coopération de recherche
sont nécessaires parfois pour pouvoir
avoir notamment dans des pays de petite
taille ou de moyenne taille des équipes
de recherche de taille suffisantes pour
pouvoir ensuite à partir de ces équipes
de recherche créer des spin-offs des
startups les pépites qui demain vont
peut-être mener des joindre et ensuite
atteindre des tailles critiques et
devenir les acteurs à l'international
alors avec qui coopérer si on veut
développer les technologies émergentes
de demain et donc assurer sur le long
terme la souveraineté technologique de
l'Europe et faut-il sécuriser la
recherche et jusqu'où
en Europe le rôle de la recherche
publique et très fort dans les
technologies émergentes je parlais du
quantique les les talents qu'on voit
émerger et les technologies de rupture
qui sont développées en Europe dans le
cantique émergent à partir d'organismes
publics par exemple en France le CEA ou
l'université Paris-Saclay
je mentionnerai des jeunes pousses comme
Alison Bob et Pascal qui sont vraiment
au niveau
plus élevé de la recherche et
technologies au niveau mondial
aujourd'hui au sein de l'Union
européenne la question de se pose pas on
coopère dans la recherche quand bien
même on serait concurrent économique
mais au-delà de l'Europe évidemment la
question se pose d'une autre manière les
États-Unis ça a été un peu évoqué par
Louis
sont dans une ambiguïté de
positionnement puisqu'il va à la fois
conserver leur domination technologique
mondiale notamment dans le cadre de la
rivalité avec la Chine tout en étant
dans une approche partenariale ce qui
crée des certains une certaine ambiguïté
et une difficulté à fonder des
partenariats de recherche avec les
États-Unis notamment aussi du fait que
la puissance de la recherche
universitaire américaine et son
attractivité crée des asymétries très
significatives en termes de moyens et
plus encore les États-Unis ont tendance
à attirer y compris les talents
européens
par ailleurs du côté américain
le capitalisme politique est évidemment
libéral et très centrée sur le secteur
privé et le secteur privé lui-même les
gafam notamment les entreprises
initialement du numérique qui produisent
des logiciels sont de plus en plus
investis dans des technologies
émergentes y compris des technologies
matérielles de hardware y compris dans
des domaines tels que le cantique je
mentionné tout à l'heure Amazon
IBM Google développe des ordinateurs
quantiques aujourd'hui
tout comme une développe aussi
évidemment dans le cas d'Amazon
notamment des systèmes satellites des
câbles sous-marins etc
or ces grandes entreprises privées ne
sont pas dans l'obligation de publier
leurs recherches donc on a des
situations où Alison Bob spin off de la
recherche publique française publie ses
résultats et son concept d'ordinateur
quantique
et Amazon développe un concept
d'ordinateur quantique sur la base de
cette recherche publiée par cette
start-up française
on a donc une asymétrie des acteurs et
de leurs pratiques qui posent question
on a aussi des enjeux de propriété
intellectuelle puisque nombreuses nombre
de nos chercheurs utilisent des
plateformes de Cloud y compris
notamment Amazon Web Services
où on a des enjeux de propriété
intellectuelles ou en tout cas de
protection de la recherche qui est menée
sur ces plateformes cloud américaines
en raison de des conditions de vente si
vous voulez ou de d'utilisation de ces
plateformes qui ne protègent pas
complètement
les utilisateurs côté chinois on est sur
un autre type d'enjeu mais non des
moindres notamment quand on voit
peut-être un certain degrés de naïveté
dont tu as fait preuve l'Europe
vis-à-vis de la Chine
jusqu'à aujourd'hui une politique
évidente du gouvernementale du côté
chinois d'exploitation de l'ouverture
des milieux internationaux de la
recherche avec une faible transparence
côté chinois et les enjeux de la fusion
civile aux militaire c'est-à-dire le
fait que les entreprises chinoises
peuvent être
réquisitionnés par le gouvernement et
par la défense chinoise à fourni un
ensemble de données je renvoie
d'ailleurs à ce sujet là au rapport du
Sénat de 2021 sur le sujet des
ingérences internationales dans la
recherche en France et ailleurs
alors asymétrie dans ce cas là de
l'ouverture conflit de valeurs et de
pratique il va falloir effectivement
réviser
la degré coopération avec la Chine mais
se pose aussi je disais au tout début
l'Europe est un ensemble d'autres pays
les questions de ce qu'on appelle
maintenant de plus en plus le middle
ground les middle power tous ces pays
qui sont au milieu mais en dehors du
trio Europe États-Unis Chine je laisse
la Russie de côté puisqu'elle s'est
elle-même coupée des réseaux
internationaux en tout cas ça devient de
plus en plus dépendant de la Chine c'est
en coupé du monde
occidental ces états ces puissances
moyennes puissances du milieu je vous
renvoie à une étude de lyrics sortira la
semaine prochaine sur leur politique
numérique et technologique
pour la plupart ce sont des pays qui
n'ont pas choisi un positionnement
tranché vis-à-vis de l'Europe de la
Chine et des États-Unis sargement ce qui
a été dit précédemment sous la fluidité
du système international actuellement
c'est des pays qui peuvent pour certains
présenter une valeur ajoutée
en termes de collaboration pour des
technologies émergentes mais qui en même
temps peuvent aussi être des concurrents
et je pense ici au Royaume-Uni à
l'Australie à la Suisse qui sont à la
fois des pays ayant une très forte de
très forts écosystèmes de recherche mais
qui sont aussi des concurrents
économiques ou alors des pays avec
lesquels les relations politiques
actuellement ne sont pas favorables et
on a enfin des pays qui sont demandeurs
qui sont des petits des pays peut-être
un peu un moindre degré de développement
sur le plan de la technologie mais avec
lesquelles on peut avoir un intérêt en
termes de soft power ou aussi pour leur
éviter de nouer des alliances avec
d'autres
de développer des collaborations dans
ces technologies pour conclure on est
donc effectivement sur des rapports
peut-être un peu plus
transactionnels et contractuelle comme
ça a été dit avec avec un ensemble de
pays du met dans le ground entre
guillemets donc pour conclure les
technologies numériques et émergentes
sont des enjeux clés de sécurité de
compétitivité pour pour demain il repose
pour une large part sur la recherche et
une réflexion doit être approfondie en
France et en Europe sur l'articulation
entre la volonté de souveraineté
technologique d'une part et la volonté
et la nécessité de partenariat est-ce
qu'on peut parler d'alliance dans un
contexte aussi fluide et aussi
transactionnel c'est une question qui se
pose la France et l'Europe peuvent être
effectivement des puissances d'équilibre
mais elles doivent quand même être
sélectives et faire des choix sur avec
qui travailler et sécuriser leurs
écosystèmes de recherche pour éviter
d'être le ventre mou
de du système international dans les
technologies émergentes de demain donc
on est vraiment dans la nécessité d'une
stratégie française et européenne c'est
possible au niveau européen qui va être
au croisement de la recherche de la
politique étrangère de la politique
intérieure de la politique de défense
très difficile à articuler évidemment
tous ces acteurs et tous ces intérêts
mais ça me semble un point nécessaire
une ambition nécessaire dans le contexte
que je présentais précédemment merci de
votre attention
merci beaucoup Alice panier pour ce
portrait effectivement très très
utile Sébastien Jean vous avez un défi
qui est très compliqué parce qu'il
s'agit d'introduire la notion de jeux
économie vous avez 10 minutes donc
j'insiste sur ce point pour qu'on puisse
effectivement avoir par la suite une
séquence d'échange avec la salle donc
double défi pour vous Sébastien merci
Gilles merci pour l'invitation je vais
faire de mon mieux et puis j'essaierai
de d'entrer plus en détail dans un
article que je vais commencer à préparer
pour la revue
l'économie mondiale a connu beaucoup de
chocs très déstabilisants au cours de
ces dernières années même sans remontait
très loin depuis la crise financière la
guerre commerciale de Trump la crise du
covid la guerre en Ukraine on a vu au
travers beaucoup d'exemples comment les
tensions géopolitiques la dimension
politique des relations économiques
internationales étaient de plus en plus
importante et structurantes
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau la
dimension politique des relations
économiques internationales et a
toujours été présente il y a une sorte
d'inévitable imbrication qui est
d'ailleurs ce qui a amené Edward doude
va comme 1990 à forgé le néologisme de
géo économie
mais pour l'essentiel jusqu'à récemment
cette influence politique restée contenu
dans des règles pour l'essentiel je dis
bien et je crois que c'est ça le
changement fondamental que l'on constate
aujourd'hui donc probablement les
sanctions contre la Russie sont
l'exemple le plus illustratif tout en
étant loin d'être le seul pourquoi il
est illustratif parce que il n'y a pas
de précédent récent en tout cas de
sanctions aussi fortes contre un pays
aussi puissant et en ça c'est un exemple
qui montre combien aujourd'hui les
tensions
rivalités voire les conflits politiques
structures jusqu'au cœur des relations
internationales plus simplement la
périphérie plus dans le cadre de règles
négociées mais dans un cadre de rapport
de force directe et y compris avec des
puissances de premier plan
cela illustre je crois
très puissamment le potentiel est
d'ailleurs les limites aussi j'y
reviendrai des interdépendances
économiques contemporaines comme levier
de puissance
ça n'est d'ailleurs pas un hasard si les
deux leviers principaux de ces sanctions
sont la finance et la haute technologie
qui renvoie d'ailleurs à aux doctrines
de l'entre-deux-guerres de théories des
sanctions
en Angleterre avec la théorie l'approche
de du Trésor qui était il faut assécher
le pays en devise et l'approche de
l'Amirauté qui était il faut l'assécher
en approvisionnement ben là on a la
finance pour les devises et la haute
technologie pour les approvisionnements
les plus sensibles les plus stratégiques
et pourquoi on retrouve ces deux
dimensions parce que dans les deux cas
il s'agit de systèmes
stratégique et complexe qui ont tendance
à se structurer en réseau avec des
réseaux qui produisent des asymétries
extrêmement fortes qui peuvent être
instrumentalisées il faut de la symétrie
il faut des singularités pour
instrumentaliser la relation économique
si elle est purement symétrique on peut
pas l'instrumentaliser au fond donc il
faut choisir alors quel est le constat
plus largement le constat aujourd'hui et
je brosse à rentrer en m'ex demander de
simpliste mais c'est donc celui de l'une
des grandes puissances de ce monde qui
est quasiment coupé économiquement d'une
bonne partie de l'économie mondiale
c'est celui d'une situation où les
relations économiques entre la Chine et
les États-Unis beaucoup de critères les
deux premières puissances économiques
mondiales sont pour les deux tiers
régies les relations commerciales sont
pour les deux tiers régies par des
règles qui ne sont pas conformes à leurs
engagement internationaux étant donné la
guerre commerciale de Trump qui est dans
les les droits enfin disons les mesures
restent en place c'est une situation
dans laquelle les êtres publiques aux
entreprises sont aujourd'hui absolument
massifs dans beaucoup de secteurs et là
aussi clairement non conforme aux
engagements qui avaient écrit pris prise
qui avait été pris dans le cadre des
engagements multilatéraux on peut penser
à la Chine dont une estimation récente
très probablement sous-estimée montrent
que la politique industrielle mobilise
plus de 1,7% du PIB lors de grandeur en
France c'est un peu plus de 0,5 en
Allemagne aux États-Unis 04
on peut penser évidemment aux lois
récente américaine une fracture Act et
évidemment plus récemment in PlayStation
réduction actes qui y compris inclut des
dispositions discriminatoires dans les
aides qui le met à la disposition des
entreprises l'Union européenne elle-même
est plus timide mais elle avance
également dans ce dans cette dimension
et il faut souligner que dans beaucoup
de cas au niveau mondial on se retrouve
avec des secteurs pour lesquels l'ordre
de grandeur des subventions est massif
la situation elle est aussi caractérisée
aujourd'hui par une multiplication des
mesures de coercition économique j'ai
pas besoin je pense de revenir sur
l'inflation de l'utilisation par les
États-Unis des sanctions économiques en
particulier depuis le 11 septembre 2001
et avec une sorte de Crescendo
progressive mais il faut aussi souligner
que la Chine est loin d'être en reste
avec le Japon avec la Corée avec la
Mongolie avec la philippine les
Philippines plus récemment l'Australie
et la Lituanie bien sûr et puis la Chine
j'insiste aussi là-dessus est en train
de développer même les instruments
juridiques de prendre dans le livre
américain de certaines de certains des
instruments juridiques qui sont des
instruments essentiellement je sais pas
s'il faut les en tout cas de pression
mais souvent de coercition à l'étranger
je pense en particulier au développement
d'une loi sur les contrôles
d'exportation ou d'une loi dite
antisanction alors pourquoi en étant
arrivé là je pense qu'il y a deux
phénomènes structurants le premier et je
pense que j'ai pas tellement besoin de
revenir dessus c'est la rivalité
stratégique entre la Chine et les
États-Unis mais ce que je veux souligner
c'est que il me semble que la situation
actuelle est sans précédent
en termes d'une situation
d'interdépendance économique très
étroite souffrons sur fond de rivalité
voire même d'hostilité politique je
crois pas qui est précédent historique à
cette situation et c'est quelque chose
d'assez nouveau le deuxième phénomène
structurant je pense c'est l'urgence
climatique pourquoi est-ce qu'elle est
structurante parce que
elle nécessite des ruptures donc
premièrement ces ruptures elles
redistribue les cartes on en a un
phénomène une illustration spectaculaire
aujourd'hui avec les chiffres du
commerce extérieur de véhicules si vous
regardez le commerce bilatéral de
voiture entre l'Europe et la Chine on
est devenu déficitaire les importations
européennes de véhicules électriques ont
été multipliés par plus 2,69 ans elles
sont aujourd'hui à un niveau supérieur
au niveau structurel en tout cas en
novembre elle l'été des exportations
européennes vers la Chine donc on a une
sorte de retournement de redistribution
des cartes et absolument massive et
soudain c'est extrêmement déstabilisant
redistribution d'ailleurs il faut le
souligner qui sont international mais
qui sont aussi internes les enjeux de
redistribution de la main d'oeuvre des
de la valeur disons des revenus sont
très importants et ils sont exacerbés
par une troisième un troisième facteur
que j'ai pas voulu mettre sur le même
plan mais qui évidemment structurant
également c'est la révolution numérique
cette ruptures disons de l'urgence liée
à l'urgence climatique elles ont une
autre caractéristique très importante
c'est qu'elle nécessite l'intervention
des États à une échelle évidemment très
vaste pourquoi essentiellement pour le
dire très simplement pour investir dans
des situations d'incertitude radical
dans des situations qui plus est les
technologies en jeu sont extrêmement
capitalistiques pour développer des
techniques de rupture pour créer des
marchés dans un certain nombre de cas
l'État est souvent irremplaçable
cette intervention de l'État elle crée
une sorte de conflit d'appropriation du
bénéfice de l'intervention pourquoi
parce que on peut se dire que on limite
le bénéfice de cette intervention ou
nationaux parce que c'est une
intervention de l'État mais ça c'est
difficilement compatible avec les
engagements du système commercial
multilatéral
et puis alors on peut prendre un autre
une autre direction qui est de se dire
il faut ouvrir comme rester dans cette
concurrence ouverte mais là c'est
difficilement compatible on le voit
aujourd'hui avec le soutien politique au
fait d'aller de l'avant et au fond l'IRA
c'est le moyen que les Américains ont
trouvé la coalition politique qu'ils ont
trouvé pour enfin aller de l'avant après
les années d'immobilité qui en eux-mêmes
étaient dramatiques donc il y a une
sorte de de conflit entre des règles de
coordination internationales
multilatérale disons elle est contrainte
de politique interne qui se manifestent
en résultat faut-il pour autant conclure
de ce tableau finalement un peu noir que
je dresse qu'il y a démondialisation non
je ne crois pas il y a pas des
mondialisation elle est pas dans les
statistiques il y a un plateau il y a
une stabilisation il y a pas de tendance
établi à la baisse
elle est pas dans les institutions non
plus le système commercial multilatéral
n'a pas disparu simplement les trous
dans la raquette se forment et
deviennent de plus en plus gros on avait
essayé de concevoir un parapluie pour se
protéger du mauvais temps des conflits
des tensions aujourd'hui c'est une
ombrelle ça protège quand il fait beau
ça protège plus quand il y a une forte
tension politique
mais ça reste présent ça continue à
organiser l'essentiel du volume des
échanges internationaux donc il faut pas
se laisser aller à à penser que ça a
disparu du jour au lendemain ça n'est
pas vrai pourquoi en est-on arrivé dans
cette enfin disons dans cette situation
disons contrastée du point de vue des
relations économiques internationales
parce que l'ouverture économique est
ambivalente
le découplage la sanction la restriction
aux exportations n'est efficace que si
on arrive à infliger un coup à son
adversaire suffisamment
supérieur à celui qu'on s'infligeait
soi-même et c'est vers loin d'être une
loin d'être une évidence pardon pourquoi
parce que évidemment il y a des coûts
importants aussi pour l'émetteur des
sanctions
il s'affaiblit
en se privant de déboucher
en se privant d'approvisionnement
parfois en limitant son efficacité il
peut favoriser des concurrents également
et on voit dans des secteurs comme les
semis conducteurs que ce sont des
secteurs qui sont presque j'allais dire
maintenant nativement internationaux il
y a une telle division du travail y est
si poussé que personne ne peut prétendre
même quand il déverse des milliards de
dollars et à dispanier vient de le
décrire dans le cas de dans le cas de la
Chine
même personne ne peut prétendre
maîtriser complètement en tout cas
efficacement la filière donc
on est dans une situation où des
sanctions d'une part induisent leur
adaptation leur défense immunitaire la
Russie est aujourd'hui un laboratoire
que tout le monde observe avec beaucoup
d'attention pour voir la réponse c'est
également des outils qui suscitent des
sortes de vaccins par anticipation les
Russes avaient essayé de le faire
justement se préparer à l'avance à
résister au sens aux tensions mais le
constat c'est aussi que le découplage il
est difficile il est lent et il est
extrêmement coûteux vous avez vu sans
doute comme moi tous les analyses autour
de des difficultés d'Apple à
effectivement découpler donc on a une
arme à double tranchant qu'il faut
utiliser avec parcimonie au fond quand
on dresse un mur dans des relations
internationales de quel côté est-on
c'est pas facile de le savoir si on est
en train d'enfermer le voisin ou de
s'enfermer soi-même
la
stratégie d'ailleurs mise en avant par
Jake chez eleven le conseiller la
sécurité nationale des États-Unis
montre bien cette volonté de cibler ce
qu'il appelle les forces multiplayer
c'est à dire quelques secteurs précis
quelques technologies très avancées
small Yard un petit pré carrément pour
celle-là on va être très agressif je
conclus parce que je suis trop long en
somme quelle est la situation en tout
cas telle que je la lis sur la recompose
cette recomposition des relations
économiques au niveau mondial c'est
celle d'une obsession sécuritaire dans
un contexte d'interdépendance
persistante et qui persistera j'en suis
convaincu et d'une urgence climatique de
plus en plus pressante la conséquence
c'est que les États sont devenus plus
interventionnistes et que l'ordre
multilatéral existe mais il est devenu
contingent
ça cette situation elle comporte des
risques évidemment qui sont des risques
de chaos dans les relations
internationales et de conflits on peut
dire que la situation est tendue mais
elle peut évidemment se dégrader
beaucoup à beaucoup des gars mais aussi
et c'est important je crois une un
risque d'inaction climatique du fait de
ces problèmes de coordination voilà et
je conclu quand même en disant que tout
ça n'est pas une facile une fatalité et
que je pense que l'Europe a un rôle a
joué pour éviter justement que ces
risques se matérialisent voilà merci
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup Sébastien
Jean pour cette intervention très très
riche et très dense et merci encore une
fois à tous les quatre pour vos
interventions ces rencontres sont donc
un lieu d'ouverture et d'échange donc
nous sommes ravis d'ouvrir ce moment
pour pour des questions je j'attire
votre attention seulement sur une chose
c'est qu'il nous reste à peu près une
vingtaine de minutes donc pour que nous
puissions pour que tout le monde puisse
avoir le plus de personnes possible et
puis savoir l'occasion de poser des
questions et que les intervenants puis
d'avoir le temps de répondre je vous
demande d'être le plus bref possible
dans la dans la concis possible dans la
formulation de vos questions voilà
nous avons
nous avons une question là-bas
merci pour vos informations précises et
intéressantes vous avez très bien montré
l'efficacité du capitalisme politique
qui est en fait un capitalisme d'État et
vous avez aussi très bien montré le
recul global de l'Europe sur toutes ces
questions notamment la voiture
électrique on pourrait évoquer d'autres
secteurs c'est vrai que en matière de
recherche fondamentale on n'est pas
mauvais mais après on n'a pas les
champions derrière
et quand on évoque le capitalisme d'État
ça veut dire qu'il faut un état
Oran ma connaissance en Europe on n'a
pas d'état on a une coopération entre 27
États qui est plus ou moins bien
organisé par la Commission européenne
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas se poser la
question sur l'efficacité de nos outils
politiques avant de chercher à résoudre
des problèmes qu'on n'arrive pas à
résoudre depuis des dizaines d'années et
dans ce contexte est-ce qu'il faudrait
pas porter notre attention sur la
proposition qui a fait le gouvernement
allemand de créer une fédération
franco-allemande ou une fédération à
quelques pays
à l'intérieur de l'Union européenne qui
aura les moyens de fonctionner comme un
état et donc d'avoir l'efficacité pour
mener un capitalisme d'État un
capitalisme politique merci merci
beaucoup on va grouper des questions
oui bien sûr
merci beaucoup pour la conférence moi
j'avais une question sur le rôle de
l'Europe particulièrement dans le
domaine des semi-conducteurs donc on a
quand même cette entreprise au Pays-Bas
ASML qui fabrique les machines qui
permettent de graver sur les puces les
vendre et récemment les États-Unis en
une grosse pression pour que la SMR
arrête d'exporter en Chine on a ils ont
déjà commencé à arrêter d'exporter des
machines les plus performantes mais
il voudrait idéalement qu'on arrête
toutes les exportations à quoi ça
conduirait déjà en termes de relations
Europe Chine d'arrêter toutes les
exportations mais aussi au niveau de nos
importations en Chine depuis
l'électronique voilà merci
bien sûr
bonjour à tous merci pour vos
interventions respectives j'avais une
question à poser vous venez de décrire
d'éteindre du coup cette nouvelle j'ai
économie mondiale dans laquelle
l'arrivée technologique entre les
saisies et la Chine tenait une place
prépondérante et je voulais savoir quel
était la place et peut-être le rôle dans
cette nouvelle dans cette nouvelle
pardon je économie de pays qui n'ont que
trop brièvement peut-être été évoqué à
savoir le Japon l'Inde et Israël s'il
fallait pour des besoins de conciliation
ne garder qu'un de ces trois pays
peut-être parlez-nous de l'Inde qui est
un immense pays et qui a priori est un
potentiel technologique assez
considérable voilà merci
merci
peut-être on peut commencer une série de
réponses
je fais un premier je vais peut-être
répondre un peu en diagonale à
l'ensemble des questions sur la
dimension fédérale alors bon après le
fédéralisme marocain c'est une question
politique c'est un débat politique dans
lequel je vais pas rentrer mais c'est
vrai que ce qui ce qu'on constate c'est
que sur les technologies émergentes on
est typiquement sur un domaine qui est
au croisement de différents
de différents domaines politiques dont
certains certaines
compétences se situent au niveau de
Bruxelles d'autres situer au niveau des
États la politique de la recherche bon
évidemment on a des programmes européens
horizon Europe donc beaucoup de
réflexions sur avec qui coopérer qui
exclure de nos programmes les plus
stratégiques ça c'est une réflexion qui
se fait de facto au niveau européen
alors après il y a des débats entre les
Français les Allemands les comités de
recherche Thierry Breton tout le monde
n'est pas forcément d'accord sur
justement
souverain qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
est-ce que c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut
coopérer parce qu'il faut faire de la
recherche uniquement avec les pays de
l'UE où est-ce qu'on peut inclure dedans
le la Suisse Israël qui sont des pays
avec lesquels l'Union européenne coopère
par ailleurs est-ce qu'il faut préserver
certains domaines technologiques
vraiment au niveau U20 mais alors après
dans la mesure où c'est aussi des
technologies qui sont potentiellement
dual les technologies du Hal c'est donc
c'est avec des applications civiles et
militaires dans ce cas-là ça retombe au
niveau des États tout ce qui est
politique de sécurité nationale donc
c'est vrai que ça crée des difficultés à
développer une stratégie qui soit
cohérente et pour ce qui est de la
politique étrangère on a une politique
étrangère européenne et après on a 27
politiques étrangères nationales et
typiquement je parlais de ventre mou je
pense que dans les technologies
émergentes dans les relations avec la
Chine par exemple on voit bien qu'aussi
certains pays européens sont beaucoup
plus ouverts à continuer à coopérer
d'autres sont plus préoccupés donc donc
c'est vrai que c'est des questions qui
se posent
et je pense que une fédération
européenne seront peu en débattre du
bien-fondé je pense que ce serait
peut-être compliqué à très court terme
mais disons qu'il faut en tout cas de
toute façon utiliser les outils qu'on
peut déjà avoir à disposition avec
l'architecture politique européenne
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui
à fond et après le débat politique c'est
autre chose
sur un sms alors
je pense qu'effectivement au niveau
européen une difficulté quand même c'est
qu'on n'est pas du tout capable
politiquement d'être aussi ferme envers
la Chine que les États-Unis ce qui est
une bonne chose dans un nombre de
domaines au sens où les États-Unis
agissent de manière unilatérale et de
manière
à bien des égards excessifs puisqu'en
fait ils ont aussi en tête avant tout
leur intérêt de sécurité nationale voilà
ça peut mener à certains excès mais mais
à l'envers politiquement l'Europe a
choisi de ne pas
de ne pas trop ouvertement discriminé de
ne pas trop ouvertement se positionner
dans une dans une confrontation
pour des raisons principalement
d'intérêt économique prise en compte de
ces intérêts économiques et aussi pour
des raisons stratégiques de choix de
disons que c'est pas que c'est
intéressant stratégique France européen
et américains sont sont différents soit
mais parce que la l'approche n'est pas
aussi confrontationnelle parce qu'on ne
pense pas forcément que ce soit le plus
judicieux sur le long terme parce que
une tension sino-américaine qui irait
jusqu'à un affrontement militaire ne
semble pas nous être dans notre intérêt
mais du coup c'est vrai que ça ça amène
à des positionnements parfois un peu
entre deux ou ce que je disais aussi à
l'instant sur les divergences au sein de
l'Europe à certains pays qui vont
prendre des positions
différentes d'autres mais je laisserai
peut-être Louis compléter sur peut-être
l'aspect semi-conducteur plus
précisément quant à l'Inde
mon propos là dessus serait
qu'effectivement c'est tous les tous les
regards se tournent vers l'un
d'aujourd'hui
l'un aussi elle-même cherche à
développer sa propre souveraineté
technologique donc c'est assez
intéressant c'est un des peu de pays qui
décident d'utiliser ce même vocable
notamment dans en développement et
l'industrie semi-conducteur qui pourrait
être une alternative
à la Chine
et et
cherche à se positionner de manière plus
centrale dans tout cet écosystème
économique
il y aura plein d'autres choses à dire
sur l'Inde en tout cas je vous renvoie
aussi à l'étude qu'on sort au niveau de
l'IFRI la semaine prochaine parce que ça
traite d'Israël du Japon de l'Inde et
aussi de six autres pays
merci je vais peut-être réagir d'un mot
sur deux aspects le premier c'est celui
des pays tiers effectivement j'ai dû
raccourcir parce que j'étais trop bavard
et ça m'a empêché d'en parler mais je
crois qu'il est ce qui est très frappant
quand on réfléchit à cette utilisation
coercitive disons des interactions des
interdépendants économiques comme levier
de puissance c'est l'importance des
coalitions c'est très net sur les
sanctions par exemple pour qu'une
sanction soit efficace pour qu'elle
fasse effectivement plus de mal à
l'adversaire que soi-même il faut
arriver à constituer une coalition
Suzanne Suzanne strange distinguais le
pouvoir la puissance structurelle faire
bouger les choses et la puissance
relationnelle arriver à embarquer à
influencer des alliés pour aller dans le
sens que l'on souhaite et bien il y a 30
ans elle faisait le constat que la
puissance structurelle était l'élément
important je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans une situation où au contraire la
puisse étant donné cette intrication
internationale des relations économiques
et des économies au fond la puissance
relationnelle et devenue extrêmement
importante et donc évidemment on a des
pays qui sont clés dans ce domaine quand
on pense aux technologies on pense
notamment au Japon ou à la Corée on voit
d'ailleurs tous les efforts des
États-Unis pour développer qui une
alliance sur les semis conducteurs qui
un partenariat un dos Pacifique
économique indopacifique et une alliance
pour la prospérité l'Amérique etc tout
d'accord qu'ils ont un peu du mal à
auquel ils ont un peu du mal à donner
suffisamment bien de façon suffisamment
cohérente à donner corps mais enfin on
voit bien les tentatives on voit les
tentatives de la Chine aussi de
constituer une sorte de partenariat
antioxydantal de se créer au moins des
appuis vis-à-vis de au moyen de ces
politiques telles que les routes de la
soie et beaucoup d'autres donc c'est
quelque chose de crucial et l'un
d'effectivement est un pays très
particulier dans ce domaine étant donné
sa démographie étant donné également son
positionnement et son son géographique
des stratégies et donc
je crois qu'il y a il y a là un rôle
pivot de l'Inde même si on voit bien
notamment dans les difficultés de
relocalisation des entreprises
américaines que l'Inde aujourd'hui c'est
loin d'être la Chine en terme de
puissance économique et technologiques
donc c'est peut-être l'avenir enfin
aujourd'hui ça reste quand même
une puissance de second rang par rapport
au plus grand deuxième aspect c'est
votre question sur l'Union européenne
alors moi je suis pas vraiment je me
sens pas qualifié pour parler des
aspects politiques
purement de projet de plus grande
intégration ce qui me paraît clair c'est
que effectivement ce retour de des
rapports de puissance ne met pas
l'Europe sur son le terrain sur lequel
elle est plus à l'aise parce que de
façon historique structurelle elle a été
conçue précisément pour diluer pour
domestiquer les rapports de puissance
donc
effectivement c'est assez difficile pour
l'Union européenne de
disons de trouver le bon positionnement
dans ce contexte et finalement c'est ce
qui explique aussi que ces tensions que
je décrivais entre les contradictions ou
les conflits internes et les conflits
externes il s'exprime différemment en
Europe de ce qui ce qu'on voit ailleurs
quand on me demande par exemple si les
Européens doivent faire comme les
américains sur l'Iran je ne pense pas
parce que les américains c'est la façon
dont ils ont ils ont trouvé de mettre
autour de la table autour d'une loi
finalement les industrialistes les Verts
et puis les gens qui se préoccupaient
plus d'emplois ou sociales mais nous en
Europe si on fait la même chose et on a
un jeu à trois étages pour reprendre un
peu les dichotomies notamment de Robert
Pullman mais on doit mettre d'accord au
niveau européen mais aussi les les
différents
groupes d'intérêt au niveau national
mais aussi les États membres entre eux
et on sait très bien que et à certains
indétermantes qui n'iront jamais à qui
n'accepteront jamais d'aller dans cette
direction donc il faut trouver des
compromis enfin disons il faut tenir
compte de cette spécificité européenne
je crois c'est crucial et on voit bien
d'ailleurs qu'aujourd'hui y compris pour
ce plan industriel pour le Green Deal
l'ex enjeux les plus difficiles à
résoudre sont dans la façon d'articuler
une volonté d'ambition au niveau
communautaire mais aussi des divergences
sur la façon de les mettre en œuvre
sur la question fédérale la réponse que
j'aurais c'est
j'y vois pas les aujourd'hui les
préconditions politiques mais je veux
souligner le rôle du grand continent
pour bâtir un des bas stratégiques au
niveau européen pas forcément pour aller
vers une robe fédérale mais il y a quand
même je pense pas je pense que le grand
continent a peut-être eu un rôle mais il
y a d'autres choses on a vu quand même
un plan de relance européen avec des
emprunts communs il y a 10 ans c'était
inenvisageable c'était impossible et on
nous a dit il redit que c'était
impossible ce n'est pas le cas donc moi
j'ai par exemple beaucoup aimé la
lecture de Luke et du passage à l'Europe
et
en coopérant de plus en plus proche tout
en gardant leur souveraineté et en fait
dans une Europe qui décrit lui quand
même assez intérêt tactique on voit
qu'on peut faire de plus en plus de
choses
et éventuellement avoir des
nouveaux emprunts on en a parlé en
réponse à l'IRL je ne sais pas si on y
arrivera mais c'est en discussion
sur l'Inde
aujourd'hui ils ont il y a peut-être un
intérêt pour coopérer avec l'Europe mais
l'Inde c'est quand même un champ de
bataille de la confrontation
technologique entre les États-Unis et la
Chine il y a quelques quelques faits
intéressants il y a eu une très fort
investissement à la fois des entreprises
technologiques chinoises comme Tencent
et Alibaba en Chine et aussi
des vicides des financeurs des Ventures
capitales qui ont pris énormément de
participation dans la scène
technologique indienne
il y a eu une forme de coups d'arrêt
après les conflits à la frontière en
Himalaya avec notamment un ban de toutes
les applications chinoises
et il y a aussi les États-Unis et
notamment les grands acteurs des
technologies qui avancent leur pion le
principal point peut-être à retenir
c'est le futur ce qui est présenté comme
le futur gaffe femme chinois qui est Jo
une entreprise
au départ des télécommunications qui a
fortement développé la 4G en Inde et qui
possède un certain nombre de plateformes
c'était il y a un ou deux ans et il y a
eu à quelques semaines ou mois
d'intervalle vraiment très proche une
prise de participation de Google une
prise de participation de Facebook sur
des montants de plusieurs
je pense que c'était 5 et 10 milliards
ou deux fois 10 milliards mais des
sommes très importantes soit une je
pense une dizaine de pour cent de Jo
chacun donc deux pays qui avancent leur
pion sur la scène technologique indienne
beaucoup plus que l'Europe
nous avons encore une dizaine de minutes
avant de d'entendre les conclusions des
présidents
des présidentielles du Sénat et poser un
Cambo donc nous avons encore le temps
pour prendre quelques questions je sais
pas s'il y a des réactions dans la salle
et moi j'ai une question c'est
et la guerre la guerre dans tout ça
parce que là on parle de la guerre du
crâne tout ça mais est-ce que dans les
hypothèses sur lesquelles vous
travaillez
vous considérez que la potentialité de
voir comme on le voit aujourd'hui
s'étendre le recours à la guerre
devient
très crédible dans les scénarios que
vous évoquez
et si c'est le cas ce qui est évidemment
à des échelles plus importantes que
celles qu'on connaît aujourd'hui ça
deviendrait quand même très effrayant
est-ce qu'il y a dans
des stratégies à développer qui
pourraient déminer ces possibilités
c'est une question aussi au fond de
oui bonjour merci beaucoup de vos
interventions très intéressantes et très
complémentaires et
utile pour ma part j'ai une question sur
les technologies vertes en tant que
technologie du futur et on pourrait dire
peut-être dans certaines mesures en tant
que technologie émergente alors il
s'agit d'un sujet très important dans
les relations de compétition de
concurrence si nos américaines et
j'aimerais bien entendre vos réflexions
si vous en avez sur des enjeux
économiques géo économiques de ces
technologies
des aspects sécuritaires s'agit-il des
technologies qui peuvent avoir qui
peuvent être sécurisés dans les
relations notamment aussi américaine ou
au delà qui peuvent être arsenalysés oui
non et surtout la place de la France et
de l'Europe sur ce sujet à la fois dans
la compétition aussi américaine dans les
technologies vertes donc voilà et
peut-être
partenariat alliance que la France
l'Europe devrait mener peut-être
éventuellement avec les États-Unis ou la
Chine dans ce domaine merci
merci c'est une dernière question
allez
bonjour une question que je me posais
c'est s'agissant des technologies
critiques est-ce que vous pensez que il
faut une auto suffisance ou une
autonomie stratégique au sein de l'Union
européenne ou est-ce que pour certaines
technologies particulièrement sensibles
il faudrait que garder un échelon
national d'autosuffisance il y a des
partenariats qui sont très nombreux
intra hueux par exemple dans le domaine
de la défense est-ce que vous identifiez
certains secteurs domaine ou
technologies où il faudrait garder une
eau suffisance nationale ainsi
merci beaucoup donc une dizaine de
minutes pour répondre à trois questions
tout à fait simple on peut commencer par
vous Sébastien Jean et conclure avec
ces questions particulièrement
ambitieuses
bon je vais
j'ai pas de boule de cristal pour savoir
pour connaître les risques probabilités
de guerre je pense que clairement
l'illusion sur laquelle les relations
commerciales suffirait à l'éviter en
tout cas être si elle a jamais
été présente et épanouie mais je crois
que il n'en reste pas moins que
justement pour se préoccuper pour
essayer de limiter les risques de guerre
il faut essayer de garder à
une coordination autour de bien commun
et c'est pour ça que je crois que
aujourd'hui dans la situation de tension
qu'on a décrite il me semble que l'un
des enjeux importants c'est d'essayer
d'accepter ces tensions parce qu'elles
sont inévitables on aimerait bien
qu'elle disparaisse mais elles sont
inévitables des tensions enfin on a des
crises je vais pas perdre du temps à les
redécrire mais essayez de les délimiter
de délimiter leur champ et de dire très
bien à ce moment ici pour des raisons de
sécurité nationale parce que il y a
urgence à réagir sur le climat par
exemple on va déroger aux règles de
coordination mais on continue à
appliquer ces règles sur le reste et je
pense que c'est important pour essayer
de garder un esprit de coopération de
conserver ce qui peut l'être disons dans
la coordination internationale c'est
peut-être peu ambitieux un exercice de
limitation des dommages plutôt que de
partir à la conquête de grands accords
nouveaux mais je pense que c'est plus à
notre portée disons sur l'arsenalization
des technologies vertes évidemment c'est
aujourd'hui un des champs
d'affrontements majeur de la puissance
et de la souveraineté parce que les
technologies vertes c'est la possibilité
ce sont les leviers d'action de demain
et d'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs déjà alors
ce qui pose ce qui pose problème je
crois c'est le fait que il y a des
interventions massives des États mais
elles sont nécessaires et donc on peut
pas essayer de régler ses problèmes et
ses risques de d'arsenalization au prix
de l'immobilisation des efforts
nationaux donc il faut arriver à trouver
la façon de les gérer et c'est pour ça
que je pense que au fond les subventions
existantes pour une bonne partie et
surtout si on arrive à engommer les
aspects les aspérités les plus criantes
elles sont pas elles doivent pas
forcément être considérés comme un
problème de la recherche ailleurs ça
permet de faire protéger les
technologies ça c'est une chose en
revanche je pense pas que on soit obligé
d'accepter d'être inondé de votre
véhicule électrique chinois lourdement
subventionnés d'après une étude
américaine par exemple les subventions
chinoises à la filière entre 2009 et
2017 je crois elles étaient dans mon
temps équivalents à peu près au tiers du
total des ventes donc c'est quand même
pas exactement un secteur dans lequel on
peut parler d'une concurrence selon les
lois du marché
et puis sur la bon sur la souveraineté
je crois que comme comme d'autres
pour moi elle se définit essentiellement
au niveau européen mais comme dans
d'autres domaines la négociation et la
coordination entre état est un élément
clé de la bonne définition de la bonne
réponse aux questions qui se posent
merci à l'espagnol
oui merci pour compléter ce que disait
très bien Sébastien juste sur un point
sur la sécurité verte bon je sais pas je
suis pas spécialisée technologies verte
mais déjà un premier élément
d'indication de sécurisation c'est quand
une technologie est placée sur la liste
des technologies critiques qui sont donc
protégées selon la loi française au
moins en termes de
montant des investissements étrangers
les seuils d'investissement étrangers
qui sont tolérés avant qui est un
screening de la part de l'État et une
capacité du coup de l'État à s'opposer à
certains investissements je pense que
c'est déjà un niveau de d'indication si
on compare la liste 2019 versus fin 2021
en termes de technologie critique en
France on voit que entre 2019 et 2021
les les biotechnologies et les
technologies utiles au stockage de
l'énergie ont été ajoutés à la liste des
technologies critiques en France et un
mouvement similaire s'opère aux
États-Unis et en Chine
un point sur les technologies émergentes
niveau français ou européen c'est une
très bonne question c'est une excellente
question c'est une question qui est
difficile
dans le domaine quantique qui est celui
que j'ai étudié le plus
en fait on va avoir forcément une
articulation des deux c'est à dire que
au stade actuellement de du
développement de la recherche encore une
fois c'est une recherche qui se déroule
au niveau universitaire donc même si on
sait que c'est des technologies qui vont
avoir un tas d'impact qui sont dual en
parlant nature on les États notamment la
actuellement la France avec les Pays-Bas
et l'Allemagne encourage la création
d'équipes internationales de John Wenger
dans le cantique
avec à la fin l'idée quand même qu'il
faut qu'il y a une réflexion au niveau
de l'UE dans sa totalité sur la maîtrise
de l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur
c'est à dire qu'au moins au niveau de
l'UE on a la maîtrise pour les futurs
ordinateurs quantiques de tout ce qui va
constituer les machines des logiciels
aussi des équipes de recherche des
ingénieurs etc
après c'est parce que là on est au
niveau du développement des technologies
une fois que cette technologie seront
développées bon il y a un fort impact du
premier entrant donc effectivement il y
a un intérêt aussi un peu national mais
aussi européen d'avoir ces technologies
en premier mais après là où
l'articulation va se faire de manière
assez aisée entre ce qui va être au
niveau national ce qui va être européen
c'est une fois que les machines sont
déployées dans l'utilisation qui va en
être faite il va y avoir des systèmes
très avancés peut-être les plus
puissants qui vont être utilisés
peut-être par le ministère des armées à
des fins
diverses mais d'autres machines vont
pouvoir être accessibles à des
chercheurs enfin si on prend la
comparaison avec les super calcul
acteurs actuellement vous avez les
supercalculateurs du CEA uniquement à
des fins de
[Musique]
la dissuasion nucléaire et vous avez des
supercalculateurs européens qui sont
accessibles aux équipes de recherche au
niveau transnational pour mener des
recherches scientifiques à des fins non
militaires
après il y a voilà je pense que
l'articulation se fait entre en fonction
de la fonction de la technologie et
c'est pour ça que c'est très compliqué
les technologies émergentes parce que
voilà vous êtes vraiment à la jonction
de de ce qui est encore du domaine de la
recherche académique et ce qui est de
l'ordre de la technologie stratégique
donc
l'articulation à ce stade n'est pas
encore assez ne pas encore tout à fait
évidente merci beaucoup Lucas
je ne sais que rajouter après ces
exposés très brillants qui me paraissent
bien répond aux questions peut-être un
tout petit point sur les technologies
vertes quand on parle de
l'arsenalization de ces technologies
le point
dont je parlais de
mise en place de
futurs licences export
par la Chine c'est quand même le fait
d'utiliser qu'aujourd'hui 95% si c'est
au moins supérieur à 90% des panneaux
photovoltaïques sont produits en Chine
c'est à la fois donc la maîtrise de la
production mais aussi des technologies
qui permettent de faire des panneaux
voltaïques avec des coûts de revient qui
ont chuté au cours de la dernière
décennie qui ont été divisés je sais
plus si par 10 ou par 100 donc là dessus
et conscient de l'importance de la
transition écologique à la fois en
Europe et maintenant sur le style même
aux États-Unis que la Chine commence à
réfléchir à les articuler
oui en deux mots pour prolonger la
dernière des questions je ne peux que
citer Héraclite ici c'est à dire pour
les Mosses Pantone
guerre est masculin en grec ancien comme
vous le savez et on à l'époque
hantée diluvienne c'est-à-dire à
l'époque de la guerre froide c'était
déjà de la guerre
on avait le sentiment que
l'affrontement était principalement
politique et que c'était ce qui mouvait
le monde justement cette guerre fut-elle
froide était père de toute chose
aujourd'hui au fond rien n'a changé la
guerre est toujours père de toute chose
ou mère simplement elle se décline selon
de nouveaux aspects même s'il y avait
une rivalité technologique le Spoutnik
[Musique]
la hantise aux États-Unis que le
la Russie allait enfin l'URSS allait
prendre une sorte de précédent
technologique à vous avez déclenché des
programmes
américains énormes de ce choix la
conquête de l'espace et que ce soit bien
sûr la guerre des missiles qui était ce
dont on parlait à peu près exclusivement
quand j'étais étudiant
a été finalement d'ores et déjà un
élément clé de la de la suprématie
c'est-à-dire l'investissement dans la
technologie à dimension militaire alors
aujourd'hui elle s'est déployée partout
et vous avez parlé de ce microducteur
vous avez parlé de voiture électrique
vous avez parlé d'autres choses avec
les acteurs qui ne sont plus simplement
de pôles mais qui sont multi
multipolaires parmi lesquels les
différents clients et fournisseurs font
leur choix je retiens aussi d'un certain
nombre de débats que entendu de
remarques faites
se rostrum que le
nombre de producteurs c'est
considérablement accru et que on est
plus simplement dans des
affrontements qui étaient affrontements
Est-Ouest mais une multiplicité de
producteurs et les questions qui ont été
posées précisément sur la cohérence et
la cohésion de l'Europe comme facteur de
production sont bien sûr d'une très
grande actualité
je ne sais pas si vous avez vu le
le grand reportage du Spiegel paru ces
derniers jours sur un numéro je crois
sur la déréliction totale de l'armée
allemande par exemple qui pose des
problèmes absolument gigantesques et
énormes à la notion même non seulement
de défense européenne mais de cohésion
de cohésion de l'Europe en terme de
technologie de recherche développement
dans ce dans ce champ donc je voudrais à
mon tour remercier les les équipes du
grand continent pour avoir permis
d'avancer considérablement dans un débat
qui je crois peut informer l'ensemble
des l'ensemble des acteurs politiques
remercier le président les présidents du
Sénat la commission des affaires
étrangères qui vont et de la défense qui
vont maintenant conclure
je voulais dire un mot aussi il est
apparu et puis il a disparu mais pour
remercier celui avec lequel nous avons
été
réfléchit pour la première fois ce genre
de collaboration qui est sénateur
Jean-Baptiste blanc était apparu et puis
qui est allé faire des choses qui
doivent sans doute pas plus importantes
que les nôtres mais plus j'ai plusieurs
gens pour son travail c'est à dire voilà
donc merci à toutes et à tous en mon nom
de contributeur
occasionnel
[Musique]
de vieux frères plutôt du grand
continent et maintenant je crois que la
parole est Messieurs les Présidents à
vous
merci madame messieurs merci chers amis
évidemment je vais très modeste dans les
conclusions des que nous devons tirer
des communications tout à fait
passionnantes ce que je voudrais dire
déjà c'est combien les propos qui ont
été tenus ici et un telcologue que nous
est utile dans nos propres réflexions
nous qui sommes amenés à participer
à la définition des politiques
étrangères de notre pays politique
étrangère et de défense moi ce que je
veux retenir c'est
déjà rappelé ce que Gilles a dit au tout
début et que nous nous avons eu
l'occasion de constater dans un certain
nombre de nos missions c'est
l'éclatement des alliances traditionnels
les nouvelles alliances on mesure par
exemple assez peu les conséquences des
accords d'Abraham un déplacement qu'on a
que la Commission a fait en Israël en
Palestine a montré combien la vision
d'Israël qui est quand même un acteur
important dans la région se trouve
modifié par rapport au monde arabe
auquel il s'est confronté pendant
pendant tant d'années cette
recomposition d'alliances qui
interviennent je pense qu'elles vont
avoir comme cela a été dit à plusieurs
reprises beaucoup d'importance dans la
mesure où vous l'avez dit les industries
maintenant font de la sécurité un
élément essentiel y compris de la
souveraineté de la souveraineté
nationale
l'éruption de l'urgence climatique pour
laquelle effectivement il va falloir
certainement une prise de conscience
peut-être plus forte par rapport à
certains certaines grands pays dans la
Chine qui font certes des efforts d'un
certain nombre de domaines mais
peut-être pas suffisamment la révolution
numérique les technologies vertes j'ai
noté effectivement ces éléments tout à
fait nouveaux qui viennent bouleverser
un petit peu nos
grilles de réflexion ces nouvelles
règles qui vont
influer sur l'économie les grandes
puissances qui se confrontent vous la
vous l'avez dit les grandes puissances
qui se confondent en dehors de leurs
engagements internationaux ça ça me
semble tout à fait essentiel moi j'ai vu
accompagnant le président de la
République à Washington la manière dont
le Congrès tentait de résister la
modification de laïra il ne comprenait
absolument pas pourquoi on leur
demandait or c'était un début de voyage
du voyage du président de la République
et l'utilisation massive des subventions
qu'il faut évidemment toutes les règles
du commerce international moi je
voudrais simplement pour terminer
laisser la parole ultime au président
souligner les dépendances dont l'Europe
doit sortir que soit la dépendance
énergétique on l'a vu notamment avec le
cas allemand dépendance en matière de
santé vous vous souvenez de ce constat
pas un cachet de doliprane ne se
fabrique plus en Europe c'est quand même
une interpellation pour nous tous et ça
a des conséquences sur la recherche et
dans le domaine de la santé puisque la
santé devient un élément stratégique on
a vu qu'un covid est capable de c'est
quasiment une guerre mondiale quoi on a
vu ça pendant des années et le facteur
de déstabilisation que ça entraîné
dépendance de l'industrie ça a été
évoqué avec cette statistique concernant
les les voitures chinoises qui
deviennent plus nombreuses que les
voitures que l'Europe tout entière
exportée vers la Chine les semis
conducteurs bien sûr puis moi je
voudrais terminer sur un sujet que nous
suivons tous ceux qui concerne les
pensions en matière de défense puisque
c'est aussi un élément très important
qu'il s'agisse notamment de des liens
que nombre de pays européens qui
se sont à la faveur du congrès de à la
faveur du conflit ukrainien qui
finalement
aura rendu beaucoup de services à
l'Europe il y aura certainement
solidifié un certain nombre d'alliance
mais je pense qu'il faudra certainement
qu'on aille beaucoup plus loin pour
retrouver une forme d'indépendance qui
permette à l'Europe d'exister faute de
quoi nous serons un gigantesque marché
dans lequel est États-Unis et Chine se
serviront pour étancher leur
production et donc je crois que ces
réflexions là sont très utiles et je me
félicite qu'elles aient lieu dans
l'enceinte du Sénat et encore une fois
un immense merci pour vos contributions
et aux organisateurs du grand continent
je sais que d'autres d'autres débats
sont prévus avec des domaines un peu
différents mais j'espère que mes
collègues de la Commission de façon gère
la défense seront tirées leur miel de
toutes les conseils les constatations
que vous nous avez proposé de partager
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
d'abord on va aussi remercier tous les
intervenants de ce soir
autour de Gilles Kepel et autour de
l'équipe de grands continent Matteo Bali
qui est Gilles grissagnier un mot
puisque vous avez évoqué
la filière automobile
je vais rappeler au président de la
commission des finances un débat que
nous avons eu le 2 décembre ici au Sénat
un débat qui nous avait conduit à
proposer la majorité sénatoriale mais
même au-delà je suis président
est-ce que quelque part on maîtrise les
subventions et les aides à la filière
les véhicule électrique produit en Chine
pour permettre à une filière européenne
d'apparaître et se donner le temps nous
sommes dans un paradoxe aujourd'hui on
voit bien le poids de la décision
politique par rapport à l'émergence
j'allais dire d'une filière dans lequel
l'exécutif nous a répondu ça n'était pas
possible et je reprends les mots du
ministre qu'il y avait plus de priorité
à la transition écologique qu'à
l'émergence d'une filière je peux
comprendre ce débat entre priorité mais
au fond la priorité ça n'est pas
l'immédiat c'est l'objectif de moyen de
long terme qu'on doit pouvoir poursuivre
et répondant à la question sur la guerre
tout à l'heure posée par le
vice-président du Sénat
vous avez abordé par exemple toujours
transition économie verte avec la
maîtrise des panneaux photovoltaïques
sujet majeur dont nous sommes en train
de débattre qui nous a conduit à adopter
après un débat entre l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat une loi sur les
énergies renouvelables qui nous amènent
demain à adopter un texte sur la filière
nucléaire et nous voyons bien que les
maîtrises des technologies et la
maîtrise de ces technologies si elles ne
sont pas possédées pardonnez-moi par
l'Union européenne demain nous rendrons
dans une situation de dépendance et
l'exemple même du gaz doit nous faire
réfléchir ces primaire et c'est pas
technologique mais ce que est une
situation de dépendance
je voudrais vous dire que je vais pas
regarder du tout ce qu'on m'avait
préparé sur le sujet mais je voudrais
rappeler quand même deux ou trois choses
notre pays a quand même une tradition
d'intervention de l'État
ça reste génétiquement quelques que nous
soyons à gauche au centre à droite chez
les gaulliste cette intervention de
l'État elle est quand même prudente mais
nous devons la réinventer il me semble
que nous sommes restés c'est quelqu'un
qui est issu du gaulliste qui va vous
dire ça que nous sommes restés dans
cette vision mais qui aujourd'hui pour
partie date mais quand même qui nous a
permis des maîtrises vous l'avez évoqué
dans le spatial dans le domaine
nucléaire au début dans le domaine
numérique même si ça a été un échec et
oui ça a été un échec mais nous avons
tenté dans le domaine numérique dans le
domaine des télécommunications et donc
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la vraie
dimension c'est à partir dans notre pays
de cet héritage là comment allez dire
contaminer une partie de l'Europe qui
est toujours axée entre un libéralisme
absolu et nous avons un vrai sujet qui
est le sujet est-ce que nous continuons
avec la politique
de maîtrise
et de respect du droit de la concurrence
en Europe dans un schéma qui date il y a
20 ans est-ce qu'on empêche la
constitution de majeur européen capable
d'investir de conduire la recherche en
matière de transport
et ça c'est un sujet qui est posé
politiquement de manière majeure quand
vous empêchez de grandes entreprises
dans le domaine de transport tout
simplement de fusionner au plan de la
concurrence européenne vous avez perdu
la dimension mondiale de ceux qui
maîtrisent et je crois qu'il faut que
nous conduisons cette réflexion
collective
je pense aussi pardonnez-moi qu'il y a
une hiérarchie dans nos partenariats je
crois que le partenariat avec les
États-Unis dans le domaine des nouvelles
technologies il doit être poursuivi avec
des précautions que nous devons avoir et
que les puissances moyennes qui refusent
de s'engager dans la confrontation Chine
États-Unis il y en a nous offre des
perspectives intéressantes pour l'Union
européenne et si nous étions quelque
part je vais reprendre des comparaisons
anciennes une forme de Troisième force
pour ne pas laisser de force s'affronter
et quelque part nous rendre dépendantes
de l'une puis de l'autre voilà
quelques-unes des réflexions que je
voulais poser au plan politique ça veut
dire qu'il faut nous changer c'est une
des maximes de Descartes se changer
il faut que nous changeions par rapport
à ça ça veut dire que nous devons
conduire des réflexions et je pense
qu'une assemblée comme la nôtre peut je
dis à tous les collègues d'ici présent
contribuaient à ce changement vous avez
cité tout à l'heure un rapport du Sénat
madame
2021 sur en fait j'allais dire la prise
de contrôle par un certain nombre
certain nombre de fondamentaux de la
recherche et j'ai dire aussi les prises
de contrôle dans les décisions parce
qu'une partie des décisions qui sont
prises sont prises aussi parfois sous
une forme de contrôle et je dois dire
que c'est pour moi une véritable
réflexion voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire ça nous engage à la lucidité sur
les efforts qu'il nous faut accomplir
par l'Union européenne et par la France
si nous voulons continuer à peser dans
les affaires du monde et à conserver un
posi un positionnement relativement
autonome
nous avons eu un débat sur l'irra il y a
un mois ici au Sénat je peux pas dire
que je sortis de ce débat transcendez
transporté
j'ai eu le sentiment que quelque part
nous jouions petits bras par rapport
j'allais dire à ce qui était engagé par
les États-Unis et le président de la
République lui-même je le sais n'a pas
été enthousiasmé au retour de son voyage
de la rencontre qu'il avait pu avoir et
un autre qui aurait été les choses
auraient été la même chose nous voyons
bien qu'entre l'Allemagne et je le dis
avec sympathie pour nos amis allemands
dans la relation avec la Chine la
situation n'était pas tout à fait la
même que la vision des autres pays
européens c'est là-dessus nous devons
dégager me semble-t-il l'Union
européenne en faisant de l'enjeu de
souveraineté un enjeu non pas de repli
sur nous-mêmes mais un enjeu de maîtrise
au nom des valeurs que nous portons
parce que vous n'avez pas prononcé ce
mot là Gilles l'a dit au début
tout ça date de sens que parce que nous
décrons continuons à croire dans un
certain nombre de valeurs les valeurs
fait de démocratie fait de droits de
l'homme des valeurs qui sont faits au
fond de ce qui nous amène à vivre
ensemble d'une manière différente dans
un système dans lequel nous pensons que
l'homme a une prééminence et que par
exemple y compris c'est pour l'homme
qu'on doit régler la question climatique
de Ben et pour les générations à venir
tous les cas merci de nous avoir décapé
un peu l'esprit j'avoue que j'ai pas
toujours tout compris mais je suis sans
doute que vétérinaire et pas
universitaire mais ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est que ça nous fait du bien
et que nous devons en tirer pour la
suite j'allais dire quelques
enseignements il va falloir maintenant
que nous passions à l'issue de toutes
ces réflexions à la phase concrètes
qu'est-ce que peut faire les
universitaires des acteurs de recherche
qu'est-ce que peuvent faire des
financiers qu'est-ce que peuvent faire
j'allais dire demain des politiques ça
nous rendra au financement j'évoquais ce
matin le financement de la filière
nucléaire avec le nouveau président du
conseil de surveillance de la Caisse des
dépôts est consignations on est sur des
sujets je dis devant les collègues dans
lequel il va falloir une part
d'intervention publique et dans lequel
d'ailleurs l'intervention publique dans
le financement d'une technologie qui
continue parfois à inquiéter nécessite
une forme de réassurance par un
engagement de l'État et je crois que
c'est aussi cet équilibre là auquel nous
devons réfléchir voilà spontanément en
vous remerciant
j'allais dire tous les 6 mais au-delà de
vous 6 bien plus que ça et en remerciant
Gilles quepel un jour de m'avoir décapé
au cours d'un déjeuner sur un certain
nombre de sujets nous n'avons pas évoqué
ce qu'ils ça n'était pas le sujet de ce
soir mais comment ne pas
réimporter dans nos communautés
nationales les guerres d'ailleurs pour
faire toujours la prééminence à des
valeurs partagées merci d'être venu au
Sénat ce soir
[Musique]